as chair of the housewife committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covert 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the ways and means
committee
executive sessions on pending
legislation
out today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has asked access to
contemporariously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar into the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with hospitals 87
rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
[Music]
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs like dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
jennifer floor committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know why
good morning everyone let's begin roll
call with representative patrick abrami
here in llb
representative mary griffin
representative orry
here my office cleaning up a mess
representative ober you're at home with
the cats representative doucette
president l.o.b
your clerk is down bursting and i'm in
my home office by myself in nottingham
new hampshire representative elliott
here and my wife is in the bedroom
representative
here in my home office in salem new
hampshire and my wife and daughter are
somewhere in the house
representative nunes i'm president the
lobby
very good i understand representative
baxter is running late so we'll circle
back to him representative spillsbury
here
in charlestown at home alone good
got it representative all me
here in lebanon uh home alone
representative ames
here in jeffrey in my home office alone
representative thomas southworth
here in dover alone representative
malloy
here in greenland representative
schamberg
here l.o.b
representative edith tucker
here in randolph alone representative
gomarlo
aaron swansea alone representative
laughman i'm here in my home alone
representative gorg
good morning i'm here and alone
representative hacken phillips
good morning i'm president from my
office in concord new hampshire alone
representative james murphy
good morning i am here alone in my home
office in hanover
representative norman major
here impasto
my wife and
the other one
and representative baxter's not here
until he shows up i'll have him as
absent so currently mr chair there are
22 of us present two of us are not here
um
there's going to be a replacement for
representative griffin today
and i'm
told it would be representative
scott wallace so when he comes in we'll
okay thank you
you say wallace
wallace w
a-l-l-a-c-e
okay
should we unmute them and ask yes
uh
can you tell us uh phone number ending
they have to do star nine right yeah you
have to star six to unmute i get a text
from representative wallace maybe seven
to ten minutes late i'll get his number
okay uh representative wallace is
running late
about ten minutes he should be signing
in uh
representative just got a text from him
all right
so today we have six bills to have
public hearings on
and i also want to let you know that
we're
planning on
exacting some of the bills that we
discussed yesterday
but this morning over the radio i heard
that the governor
this budget
consists of some
reduction in business taxes
interest and dividend taxes
and mills and rooms taxes
so i'm going to hold
house bill 10
house bill 210
and house bill 568
until we find out
what these are all about
do
hold on a second
house bill 306
and house bill 330
are the ones that
plan on executing we should be able to
do that this morning because the
schedule this morning isn't that heavy
the heavy schedule is this afternoon
we have a lot of people signed up
to testify on some of these bills
so we'll go right to
which is house bill
could i interrupt for a moment
representative major yes
um representative doucet
yes um
i think there's noise coming from around
you somehow and i i don't have the
ability to mute your computer
my computer
i bet it's this over here maybe it's not
with him maybe it's this
back back here
uh
you wanna you wanna move that mic
person
see if this i'll see if this clears it
up
okay the sheet that i have for signing
[Music]
we'll start with the
prime sponsor representative lange
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee members
um
[Music]
representative wallace is in the room
here in albino
okay
so you want him to say something
we can mark him as attendant
okay
sorry sorry uh personally
that's quite quite all right
representative romney
mr representative wallace is very
important
so uh committee members thank you for
letting me introduce house bill 355 this
is another one of my one page bills
which i know ways and means doesn't get
very many of um this is a pretty
straightforward bill um this bill just
allows that in towns that have already
voted to allow kino
to allow that kino which currently only
extends to places that have poor
licenses or liquor licenses to allow the
um
keto to be expanded as a lottery product
to any lottery
like a retailer licensed location
this is a business bill
i know the retail industry is excited
for this bill they think it'll help
their industry um i i know that you know
what's going on with covid uh for
revenues this will help with the state
revenues so again a pretty
straightforward bill it just says that
in towns that have already voted to
allow kino that keno will be extended
not only to the poor licensed locations
but to the retail licensed lottery
locations as well
and i'm pretty sure i'm probably
charlie's on the phone answer questions
so you may want to refer to him but i'm
happy to ask and answer any questions
any questions from that committee hold
on one second i have to
catch up with myself
no questions from the committee uh mr
chair i i do uh i don't have i don't
have the hand feature i have a computer
in front of me that's turned on
so i i'm not i don't want to be
interrupting but
uh when when you think it's ready i do
have a question
i had
representative
representative lang i think you were on
the committee when we
were doing keno
is that correct
i was just
you are right okay so
if you remember the testimony from um
uh the uh
charlie mcintyre then
he said that massachusetts made a
mistake
by allowing keno to be in venues other
than
establishes that pour liquor
i think we i think we passed keno
because
we didn't we didn't allow it to be in
every establishment
um
and uh
this is why i just want you to kind of
give me a sense of why you think this is
a good idea
so uh thank you representative romney
for your question and i i guess i have a
little bit different recollection of of
um
director mcintyre's conversation uh
around kino um i don't remember him
saying that it was a mistake but i also
remember him saying about uh it is a
huge revenue generator from
massachusetts um and that it was one of
the reasons why we were looking to bring
keno this bill is being brought forward
i worked with the lottery on the
drafting of this bill uh when i went
into them and explained to them i was
gonna i wanted to do some bills
regarding um sports betting i told them
if they had any other bills that they
wish to bring forward i'd be happy to be
a conduit for that and this was one of
the bills that in working with charlie
that he recommended we bring forward
so i think you'll find the lottery
commission is going to be in favor of
this bill um and you can probably talk
to charlie and he can give you some
metrics and some numbers as to why this
is a good idea
i'll remind all committee members that
again kino is a local control option so
towns have to vote whether or not to
allow and even in the conversation
of allowing kino nowhere does it talk
about on the ballot
um where in the town that kino be
allowed it strictly says shall the town
allow kino um and you answer yes or no
and and that that passes
so uh i'll just leave that for the
committee representation do you know if
uh
i've admitted him
allowed him to talk
okay uh chai
uh good morning mr chairman how are you
this morning uh charlie mcintyre uh
mr chairman i think you still have a
couple hands raised for questions for me
just hold off charlie until we take care
of
the other
bring the panelists back
okay we have three hands raised
thank you mr chair
uh the question i have is um
keno seems to be a
game that you play while you're waiting
for meals and
sitting around and
it's a lounging type of an activity how
do you have a lounging activity
at a
convenience store
thank representative
for your question again i i can tell you
that um you don't have to be in the
building for keno so i could buy a
keynote ticket walk away just like i buy
a lottery ticket and walk away and wait
for the drawing and then come back and
check my ticket um those same activities
can be done in a in a retail store that
you can buy a keynote ticket walk away
and then come back two days later scan
your ticket and find out whether or not
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman i hope that that
noise isn't going to be occurring
uh
representative lang
on
isn't this a kind of bait and switch
that the towns that
took keno took it with the understanding
that it was going to be in restaurants
uh or bars with food
and it is a lounging supposed to be a
lounging activity on
they are going to be required to put it
in every convenience store if the
convenience stores want it i don't
understand why convenience stores want
it in
massachusetts unless it's just to turn
themselves into k-no parlors because
there is isn't it true that that
on
this competes directly with their
ability to have any other customers
since people are going to be waiting
around to look at the ticket
let the number come up
well again i'm sure someone from the
retail association will be speaking my
understanding is they are completely in
favor of this bill and feel that it will
be um help help their overall revenue
cycles uh and increase the revenues for
those businesses which obviously overall
increase the revenues for the state of
new hampshire so
my understanding again is the retail
industry is in favor of this bill and um
i'll leave it at that
on if i may you didn't answer my
question about the municipalities having
no voice in this being added in
to their towns
so again uh uh representative obama uh
omni thank you for your question i guess
they do have a voice and that would be
this public hearing um this is a duly
noticed public hearing they have every
opportunity they understand what bills
are coming before him i know the new
hampshire municipal association tracks
these bills that are relative to
municipalities um and cities and towns
and so i'm sure they've made aware all
the communities that are um
that are uh have voted to allow kino and
again i'll remind the um
members the ballot question that goes on
the ballot doesn't talk about poor
licenses or lounges or or liquor
licenses it strictly says shall the town
of whatever allow kino
representative
thank you thank you mr chairman um
i may or may not have this correct but
i believe it was a year or two that kino
was voted in to help fund kindergarten
is it
presumed that uh this will continue
funding that or funding other
sources i don't know if you're you're
if you're gonna
so i can i can maybe answer that
question because there's been a lot of
dancing around this issue um so yes
originally uh when keno was introduced
into the state legislature back in 2017
2017-18 i believe it was and passed it
was tied directly to kindergarten the
revenues going to kindergarten and
full-time kindergarten um in the next
term um that was the while keno was
continued the um it stripped it out as
being related directly to kindergarten
and now it just goes to the general it
goes to the education fund
okay thank you
okay
[Music]
so representative jan again to
representative romney's point we've
already moved the ball on this it was
originally voted in again under
understanding was going to go for
kindergarten and then two years later we
swapped it so it's not an uncommon
practice and the legislature change the
rules around
what a given
program is about
right question can i ask a question
uh
can i is it okay if i ask a question mr
mr chairman this is representative nunez
hold on a second
first of all
do you have the ability to raise your
hand
in person he's in person i'm in the lob
he has no laptop
oh okay yes go ahead let me let me
let me tell you who's in the yellow bee
just everybody knows it lives in nunes
wallace
bessette and schaumburg
thank you mr chairman um representative
lang good morning uh i just want to i
want to clarify something i got a little
confused uh when representative elmi was
asking her question
um
this this bill will allow
keno to go in more locations but it is
still
a local rule they they need to vote on
it in the towns is that correct
that is correct representative nunes
thank you very much representative
anybody else that's in the lobby with
question
then we before we go i have my hand up
representative ames okay representations
thank you
good make me
hard to manage i can see that
but thank you anymore
so uh representative lang this follows
up on
uh the question asked uh asked by
representative allmey
and um
you you've pointed out that the
towns that have accepted keno have voted
on a ballot question that asks whether
they
will accept or not
keno
but kino was a defined
term
as defined by statute
and at the time that that ballot
question was presented
it identified kino as an activity that
would be
occurring um not in
all retail establishments that
that have lottery
but uh
only in a list of
of kinds of places that did not extend
to
the
retail stores that
has
lottery activities so um
i don't think it's fair to say
that in voting
to accept kino in in a town
that that disposes of the question that
representative army
raised
in
it
unless you know
as a fact that when the question was
presented
the
discussion made clear that keno was
currently only in
in such and such places allowed only in
such and such places
but it might later be allowed in other
places and the authorization related to
keynote wherever it might
be allowed now or in the future
i think that there's a significant issue
here
with regard to
to the authorization that has been given
to keno by places that have voted to
allow it
and i'd like you to respond to that
sir absolutely representative thank you
for your question again i'd say it's not
uncommon for the state to uh
change a program um and again i'm going
to use kino as a direct example so towns
that voted after we passed keno were
voting based on the fact that uh in the
original bill we tied kino to
kindergarten people were voting because
they thought they were increasing um
education education spending
specifically to allow full-time
kindergarten and that was a completely
acceptable bill that went through and
then two years later and parties changed
they decided that no we want to decouple
keno from education with no thought of
what it meant to the local impact and
people that voted for those towns so
again it's non-uncommon occurrence that
we will decouple or change a rule um and
and sometimes that plays around with
who's in political power and who's not
um but again in this particular bill we
went from tino was tied to kindergarten
kino was not tied to kindergarten so and
and again no one no one argued the
argument that well when the towns voted
for this they voted because it was tied
to kindergarten um the legislature two
years ago was happy
the uh and decouple uh keno from
kindergarten with no impact as to what
the towns thought and what they voted on
so again it's not an uncommon occurrence
um we regularly do this i think um where
we have policies and procedures that
affect towns and we change those
policies and procedures that those
talents are uh have so
i guess that's my answer to the question
it's not an uncommon occurrence
you're also at
right yeah i'm going to leave it there
thank you
representative
thank you for taking my question thank
you mr chair
um
how did this bill come about did you get
requests from lottery retailers that
wanted to add it to their convenience
stores
or
i mean has a former grocery store owner
and a retail
lottery dealer i can't imagine
this happening i i mean it's
it would it would clutter up the aisles
thank you for your question
representative and again uh well what i
said what i will say is that i was
originally uh bringing bills forward
relative to um
sports betting and i met with the
lottery um and my understanding from
lottery is that yes there is a demand
for this and there is a request for this
and again you know going back to it's no
different than when people buy scratch
tickets or when people buy any lottery
tickets especially the instant ones um
some stay there and use them some leave
um and in this case again you can buy a
keynote ticket walk away come back the
next day when you're getting your coffee
the next morning and check your keynote
numbers to see if they won the day
before so there's no direct you don't
have to stand there and look at the
screen and watch what's going on you can
there are some places that
i'll give you an example of my little
town of sandbridge and here we have a
convenience store down on our on route
three that has a little breakfast place
so you get a coffee place and a lunch
place so you could go in and get a buy a
sandwich from the deli and go sit down
and if they wanted to sell keno there
they could put that up assuming our town
approved it so there are places where
retail it does work where they have
small little lunch lunch counter type
places where it may work out for them
and and help with that insulatory
revenue ancillary revenue um so again i
worked with lottery on this um it was
seemed to be a demand for it and that's
why we moved it forward
thank you
representative those are questions for
representative
yes representative major uh
i don't see my raised hand feature i
think it as a co-host it's either not
here and anyway my question for
representative lang
um
and nice to hear your voice tim
can a town put back on the let's say a
town passes kino
and now lottery makes this change
can a town put the kino back on the
ballot to perhaps revoke
uh the authorization for kino in that
town
without an absolute answer i believe the
answer is yes
we could you could probably ask mr
mcintyre that
thank you
any further questions for mr uh
see and then a call
there's only one other person that
signed up
to speak on the bill
and that is uh
kevin
d-a-i-g-l-e bagel
no i'm allowing him to he's a member of
the public
from the new hampshire groceries
association and support
so um
kevin you're on
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee can you guys hear me okay
yes
perfect i want to thank you for uh for
allowing us to speak here and
representative lang for
uh sponsoring this bill
for the record my name is kevin daigle
i'm the vice president of the new
hampshire grocers association
for those of you not familiar with us we
represent grocery stores convenience
stores wholesalers and distributors
operating here in new hampshire these
include the small independent
mom-and-pop operators as well as the
large chain operated groups
we work hard to represent the voice of
our collective membership
to ensure that they're well informed and
that they're in compliance with uh state
laws and regulations
we're here today in support of house
bill 355.
since 1967 grocery and convenience
stores have been partners with the new
hampshire lottery selling scratch
tickets and lotto games to the consumers
as well as the cashing of winning
tickets for these games up to 599
dollars
though we're not able to sell keno at
our locations retailers are able to
infrequently cash out the winning
keynote tickets now
when kino was originally proposed
our organization had testified on behalf
of retailers so they would be able to
participate in keynote when and where
communities allowed
the original bill allowed only for
restaurants and buyers to participate
while excluding the longest partners of
the new hampshire lottery retailer
as mentioned earlier our retailers are
already able to cash out these winning
keynote tickets we think it's fair the
next step would be allowing retailers to
participate by selling keno to our joint
consumers
representative elmi and gomarlos both
brought up a couple of points
um
not all of our members
would jump at the
keynote and participate in keno if it
was available
that would be a decision again based on
the community first if it was allowed
then a business decision for those
businesses within those communities it
was something that um
would fit their model
representative only brought in you know
could you have people loitering around
you could
what we found from our members
that have
locations in other states that allow
kino is that most of these are are doing
single purchases when they're cashing an
existing winning keynote ticket they're
buying an extra ticket with their
winnings
going and do their shopping and coming
back and checking it getting a coffee
and checking it
or taking off leaving and coming back at
a subsequent visit
we've had others
you know that have now you go into a
convenience store it's not your typical
convenience store
you've got these these giant sitting
areas and dining areas
those would be locations where you could
possibly see keno really taking a
foothold
but but our retailer would do a good job
of making sure like they do now with
scratch tickets you have a couple people
who sit there and they'll scratch their
scratchers and turn them in and
take the winnings buy some more and
scratch them but they're there for
five ten minutes at a time
i i don't think the retailer would allow
for the continued longevity of somebody
just sitting at the counter so they
would do a good job of moving along so
with those thoughts
we encourage the committee in supporting
the passage of house bill 355
i thank you for your time and i'd be
open to any questions that i may help
with
uh representative major
representative
thank you um kind of refresh our memory
as to there's got to be a reason that
you want this for your store all the
stores um
what is the what is the percent or
uh
incentive to the to the stores to to
have keno uh
what i guess basically what what does
the store make
uh financially from doing this
there is a commission that's made on the
sale of the ticket
um
i believe on aquino
it's in charlie
if i'm wrong i believe it's eight
percent
sale of that ticket
okay thank you we'll follow up with
representative elmi
thank you mr chairman
on this is a follow-up to that actually
uh what's the percentage on a scratch
ticket
i believe that is at five percent
it is definitely less than what kino is
now
and that's an argument
we've had in the past
yes yes i think it speaks for itself
unmute
okay thank you
the gist of this is that
a lottery retailer
is licensed
if the town has already voted
to allow uh the sale of keno
uh of course we we were into that here
in salem new hampshire a while ago
my question to mr mcintyre is
um how long does that
stay on the books
if a town
uh has already
allowed it so in other words
uh
when does the
rob are you asking mr mcintyre or mr
davis
no i said charles mcintyre
he's
mr daigle is the one testifying right
now so do you have a question for mr
daigle oh oh i'm sorry okay
i'll wait
okay then we will bring in charlie
mcintyre thank you
and bob you you can ask your question as
i was saying
uh we've already voted for keno in salem
uh we're uh
you know
uh we have a long history of gambling
because the racetrack used to be here
and so people uh 80 percent uh supported
keno
so my question to mrs mcintyre is
how often do we allow new people
to come in or new towns to come in
in order to have uh
this possible
is the bill
is the law
for salem is that perpetual is that for
the next 50 years
and what how does a new town
apply do they apply directly to the
lottery commission
how does that work
uh good morning mr representative elliot
this is charlie mcintyre um
so
we went for the first approvals for
towns and cities when kino was adopted
and salem obviously approved it
we would
not
disapprove it unless the tanner city
itself disapproved it which is similar
to how lottery was adopted the state in
the first place
when lottery was adopted in 64
there were about 20 cities and towns in
new hampshire that said no
and that tickets weren't sold in those
towns and cities until they eventually
approved it uh oddly i still think there
are three or four towns in new hampshire
that completely disapprove of lottery
sales
further questions
[Music]
your hand sorry thank you uh charlie if
this passed and
on the convenience stores came in i
cannot remember from the original bill
in any way the original bill seems to
have considerably changed in the senate
so that a number of the enforcement
issues that
not enforcement but on
issues of the way the rooms were
structured
have been taken out i did not realize
that but on
if if this passes
uh
and
that
then
does
the
uh grosser have to the convenience store
owner have to pay for anything in the
installation or is it like lottery where
i believe you
you uh provide everything that they need
to make it work
uh thank you for the question
representative so
it's my understanding they would pay the
license fee for kena which i believe is
um the remainder of the equipment and
services and the communications would be
paid for by us
and this would be a store-by-store
decision so
those that wanted it would
take it and those that didn't would not
similar to bars and taverns now
we probably get one in four bars
in every jurisdiction where it's been
approved
thank you if i could follow up so what
you're saying is is it an annual license
fee of 500
yes
and for the five hundred dollars then
after that they get
uh eight
eight percent of the ticket value what
is the license fee for annual license
fee for
uh
on lottery
uh thank you for the question
representative there is no license fifa
lottery
mr chair of representative
um again i can't raise my hand so when
you're ready i have a question
i see mr representative says before me
though
um
hold on
jenny jen
is there any way that the people
participating from the lob
no but i was going to suggest that one
person be designated to
write down who had their hand up first
and
until patrick or patrick
keep track
but could you do that
uh yeah i'm doing that i mean then how
am i going to communicate other than the
way i've been doing it
uh yeah the guys have been doing that
they've been if they wanted to ask a
question they're they're they're
reaching out to me so fine uh but we
don't have the ability to raise the hand
here
when somebody has physically raised
their hand it could be entered into the
chat
there is no chat
um
okay
yes but maybe i i have a suggestion
representative asks that's a question as
a discussion in other committees i've
seen uh the
the questions from the committee be
divided in half go to the people who are
online first and then ask if there's
anybody in the in the lob that wants to
to speak after that just divide it up so
that you get everybody covered
that's a good suggestion we'll do that
and now
if members of everybody will remind me
yes
i think if there are too many of us
trying to ask questions that might not
work maybe every four people
online you could go and ask
representative abrami if there are
this afternoon for instance it might be
a mess
right
we'll go we'll try the system out and
see how it goes
okay
there's only one person
online
that's right represent representative
ames you have a question then we'll go
to the lobby okay thank you
um i just wanted to nail down a couple
of facts uh
with charlie mcintyre and uh
they relate to questions that were asked
before he came on
and so there were two questions
one was
community
town that has
voted to accept kino
wishes to
um
[Music]
leave kino
you know to unaccept
and uh what's
what's uh
is there any history on that in the
lottery or what's the understanding of
lottery on that question and then the
question the other question uh it was
asked by
others uh related to the commission and
uh the five percent versus eight percent
um
lottery retail scratch tickets versus uh
keno um that's what the answer was five
percent for scratch tickets and eight
percent
for keno and we just i just like to have
that stuff confirmed yeah that's very
charlie yeah certainly thank you
chairman representative ames um
certainly we would respect the senior
town that voted to reverse it and we
would shut it off in that city or town
if they indeed did so um we would not
sell keno the town didn't didn't want it
so that's the answer to the first
question
second one is yes that's correct the
commission rate uh for kino is eight
percent
the commission rate for other lottery
sales is five percent but we have
certain bonuses and cashing bonuses and
uh
bonuses for selling winning tickets so
our actual commission rate is about five
point eight five point nine percent for
stores that sell lottery tickets it's
five percent plus it's the best way to
describe it
uh like for example if you sold a
winning powerball ticket
you get a check for seventy five
thousand dollars so that's included in
okay
follow-up
good that's that's helpful um so can you
uh
what's the rationale what's
that
what's your understanding of the reason
for
the higher rate for keno
uh thank you for the question that was
actually part of a community discussion
back when this was approved and it was
based around a higher commission rate
would
make adoption faster for bars and
taverns
because it would be in essence the
lowest margin of product in a bar at
eight percent uh and
if it was lower than that adoption would
be
slower and
you know less broad-based
is the eight percent based upon
the net or the gross
uh thank you for the question mr
chairman it's based on the gross and so
if you sell a dollar ticket you get
eight cents
and so and if i could add numbers to
that mr chairman the average keno
location today
sells about 670
per day per location so you're talking
they make about 50
a day
on average selling kino currently and
that's an average obviously you have
stores that sell or bars that sell much
thank you
names do you have any further questions
i do have one further follow-up question
based on
charlie's response
and that is
it sounds like the rationale for the
higher rate related to bars and
restaurants and
their margins um
and so the question obvious question is
well what about the uh
places that the retail places that this
bill would add does that same rationale
hold for uh those establishments where
scratch tickets are
are currently authorized
it does representative so as kevin
daigle said um we've received this
request from a number of retailers
who actually live in jurisdictions that
approve kino who actually cash keto
tickets that can't sell it uh and so
there's a frustration amongst them
that they're cashing winning tickets for
products they can't sell
uh and so
at a higher rate and so that's the one
of the rationales behind this request of
okay thank you
representative romney
questions from the llb yeah
i have one major question but uh to
follow up on a couple of these so that
so when that when these stores uh when a
grocery store cashes out
they're getting what are they getting
for that
five percent is that what you're saying
no they don't because they didn't sell
it they don't get anything for it all
they get is the fact that
in yours in that store
somebody is getting cash and hopefully
making a sale something else
okay
just trying to understand that
but uh you had my introductory comment
about
the history of keno in massachusetts
and i used to call you mr kino because
you were involved so much of in getting
that going in in massachusetts
and you got to tell me if my
recollection of what was said when we
had the hearings
about
keno
came to be in massachusetts but shortly
after it was occurred
i i used the term
the legislature recognized that there
was a mistake made that that having it
in heavy convenience store wasn't a good
idea
my understanding is that if if i was a
convenience store now that wanted to do
implement you know they can't do it
because the law has changed in
massachusetts am i correcting my
remembrance of all that
so you're partially correct
representative well it's better not
being correct at all so i'll take that
again
so what keto was passed in 93 in
massachusetts
it was actually at the direction of the
legislature the lottery nothing to do
with it
and it was
this legislature who had inserted
funding and said lottery you will
start kino it will be by this date and
you will make this much money
um
and thereafter
there were some legislators and
elected officials in towns which are
very much against gambling
who
were upset and so as part of a
negotiated settlement as it were
it was limited only to bars and taverns
in mass for a number of years
but there were still about 400 locations
in mass that had already been enabled to
sell keno in convenience stores
thereafter
everyone realized you know this really
wasn't a problem in stores and so it was
opened up to cities and towns across the
state
i will tell you that
certainly under the mass old technology
it would have been almost impossible to
not sell keynote tickets in stores it
would have been an on or off switch as
it were
but we have the ability that bass didn't
have at the time to sort of geo-locate
keynote locations by towns and cities
that can approve it um so
you know it's hard to explain
certainly mass politics but um it was
they wanted it all in
then they wanted only these bars and
taverns but they had grandfather they
had about 400 locations and so that's
clarification
[Music]
so
again
going back to the debate we had several
years ago when we voted this in
um i don't think any of the members like
the fact that we had that we had the one
store that one gas station i forget what
townington
run the border of the parking lots in
new hampshire but the gas station and
convenience store was in
massachusetts
the concern of that is that they
stripped everything out of that
convenience store
and we're just selling
keynote tickets well i would say
i'm sure you know we can remember the
internet store
we didn't want that that that was one of
the reasoning behind
i think uh
bringing it to just the uh facilities
that poured liquor
am i correcting that that store still
exists in massachusetts yes the store is
called ted's mobile it's actually
methuen
um
you're right the parking lot is in new
hampshire and the building is in
massachusetts but those are there's only
a couple of those of this
seven thousand locations in mass that
are licensed to sell keno
i think there's only in my memory this
could be
old memory but in my memory my time
there there were only two locations like
that in the entire state
one is in
methuen the one you described and one is
in fall river it's called vista donuts
um it's on the rhode island border
and they sell like 12 donuts a day and
nothing in aquino lottery tickets
thank you charlie uh follow up again
follow up
charlie i i just want to make sure
uh when representative lang kind of
characterized your involvement with this
uh i'm assuming that lottery doesn't
take a position on this correct
it doesn't certainly but i would i will
tell you certainly
we have received lots of commentary from
our retail network asking for this
um and that's not
a common thing for us we really have
seen a lot of commentary a lot of
requests to forward this as you know
we don't like to
support gambling expansion only because
we like to regulate it and operate it
and not be part of the
moving it forward
we also leave that to you folks to
decide that obviously the governor to
decide but um i will tell you that we've
received a significant number of
again follow-up follow up
so again and this is for the committee
too the
part of what we the reason we kept
limited to the bars
places the port liquor was the
aesthetics of it all
do we want keno
being played and you know i'm sure
there'd be a lot of people in in the
grocery store going grocery shopping
that don't want to see
keno being played there that was our
logic then
uh
so uh
was i running out charlie i think that
was part of our logic then
it was and honestly to that extent
if it's a business like a grocery store
it would be unlikely they would sell
keto it would be more likely that it'll
be a place like a sandwich shop that
would sell keto that has a breakfast and
lunch menu
where you would stop have a sandwich and
play keto a couple of times that they'd
leave
kino sales as
you may know you can buy a ticket and
leave and check your numbers on the our
website
thereafter
thank you charlie on set
anybody else in the in the llb
i love you so sad
okay
anybody else want to testify for
thank you mr chairman um
just had a quick question on the um for
mr
mcintyre um
the on keno the um
the commission is eight percent could
you remind me what the state
percent is
sir certainly representative good
question um
it varies slightly but it's
approximately 19 percent so every dollar
sold is about 19 profit uh this year
we'll net around 8.5 9 million dollars
in sales
um
covid was brutal for sales as you can
imagine but sales have been accelerating
the last couple of months so
we're averaging around 950 000 a week so
that'll yield us around 8.5 million
dollars for the year
follow-up
um what um and is it a similar
percentage to um general scratch tickets
uh good good questions uh representative
it depends on the scratch ticket so a
one dollar ticket it had pays out at 60
so
every dollar you sell at a scratch
ticket's a dollar
the prize is 60
at a 20 ticket or 25 it's approximately
and so the margin varies by scratch
ticket
similarly a scratch ticket so any
aggregate scratch tickets those are
around 20 profit margin
mr chairman sorry i was trying to write
and now oh yes enforcement
on
how much more difficult is this going to
make it for
your enforcement if all the uh conv most
of the convenience stores are selling
and i'm talking i know you can do part
of the enforcement online but you cannot
tell on whether people are allowing
and i presume that this will have to be
added into your
controls that we haven't heard about yet
on that have on that are trying to
locate people that are over
over playing and spending beyond their
uh certainly when it comes to store by
store it's difficult to
limit sales as you can imagine it's the
equivalent of stopping somebody from
buying too much coffee if they go to
store to store the store to store we
can't stop that um
the stores are on their own to control
products like this that are age
controlled similar to cigarettes similar
to beer um
and we have an enforcement division but
it's
on the stores to control what they sell
okay anybody else wish to testify for or
against
house bill 5 uh
on the blue sheet
there are seven people that have signed
up and support
senator major
yes representative
but um i just wanted to to point one
thing out to representative lang
um
if that's okay
the one sentence
really isn't grammatically fluent mate
and i know he was particular about
another bill 354 so maybe he wants to
look at that and fix it
that's all thank you
representative you're still with us
i'm sorry i heard it i'll re-read the
bill and see what it looks like again
it's what ols drafted but
if it needs some sort of amendment to
clean up language i'm happy to work with
someone on the committee to get an
amendment drafted before it's exact
thank you representative
i believe that it would be fluent if you
read the context it's just one of a
number of
of groups that is allowed all the others
have liquor licenses that is allowed to
to
sell
say that again
on
it this is not a complete sentence
number on lines three to five oh okay
you're talking about that yes
and i'm glad that representative camaro
asked that question
and
so representative lying is going to take
a look at that
because if he doesn't
okay on the blue sheet there's seven
people signed up
we have
four legislators representative
uh party check
hugh
johnson and your caller
and then for
members of the public
alexander and manila
nicholas thomas
and eric rothburn
nobody signed up in opposition
but i don't see any but for the hands
okay so i'm going to close the public
next
go to public hearing uh
on house bill 364.
hospital 3 house bill 364
expanding the definition of charitable
organizations to include fraternal
organizations for the purpose of holding
rafters
representing yearly is the prime sponsor
jordan
wrap this on your eye
okay
yeah
the name is
well i was just informed that
representative gorg lost her raised hand
function so maybe something's going on
with muting and unmuting yourself as
well i
i don't have a you i don't have the
raised hand functioning either
nor do i
and i haven't all
really for some time
yeah representative major uh
representative oliver had to step away
just for a moment i just spoke to him
he'll be right on
okay
jen suggested i log out and log back in
to see if it comes back but now that
it's happening to everybody
well we have the technical guy
uh norm there's a technical guy in
sitting in room 201 i want to get him
um what i see jordan is muted
yeah if he stepped away okay
i i was wondering if representative
wallace and ducette have the raised hand
function that they could use in the lob
and mine's working and representative
wallace
yes i'll lower it now
okay well that well that would help if
okay
i see representative jordan muraling is
here jordan
yes we want to introduce your bill
hospital 364.
which one's that
[Music]
an act expanding the definition of
charitable organization
thank you thank you i i just
i don't recognize them by numbers i'm
sorry yeah house bill 364 is relatively
simple it just
uh expands the definitions of uh
[Music]
let me look it up excuse me i was
all the bill all that this bill does is
open up the definition of a charitable
gaming to allow a larger uh fee
for uh
raffle tickets if i'm not mistaken is
terrible organization to include
fraternal organizations for the purpose
of building raffles yeah okay thank you
all that just adds
uh fraternal organizations of any kind
so long as they're irs approved
entities are registered with the irs as
a
fraternal benefit society that would
include the knights of columbus and it
would include
the
masons as
organizations that could on their own
accord without setting up a separate
any questions
representative
thank you mr chairman
um
representative laurie have you got
a list of what all of these new places
that would be allowed to do it
on what those definitions from the
internal revenue code
cover
i started
i looked them up and on
i looked up c2 first and got this
lawyer's long just
uh discussion of how complicated c2 is
now c2 in general is
nothing more than a
educational
facility of any particular kind that
uh c uh uh eight is a non uh is a
not-for-profit fraternal benefit society
and c-10 is a large society
um
so
it would just include those names
without having to go up and set up a
separate uh
entity to engage in gaming there are
non-profits by def by because our
non-profit definition in the state of
new hampshire is so big you can drive a
semi through it
actually you could buy five of them
abreast through it
but uh
this just uh clarifies to a degree
uh
what the uh what entities are allowed
okay that um that's what worries me i
hope we can get a lawyer's disposition
uh discussion of this at some point
thank you
all right thank you ma'am
representative jennifer
thank you mr chairman i'm wondering
whether this
my question's
somewhat similar to representative almis
in that
does this mean that now churches for
instance would be
able to do charitable gaming
uh actually i think they're already
allowed
okay
represent hacking phillips
do you
i don't see a raised hand but i see your
hands visually
yeah i lost i lost my ability to raise
my hand so thank you mr chair
um i do a fair amount of work in the
nonprofit sector and um i can follow up
on some of the answers
um
so for instance 501 c 3s are tax
tax-exempt organizations that are
charitable in nature
medical organizations
of a certain kind
as well as educational
organizations so we're talking about
your traditional nonprofits under the
501c3 that you would think of
501 c2s are title holding companies um
representative ellery spoke to the
educational trust funds and i think that
it's one subsection of that category um
501c8s are lodges or fraternal
organizations
and 501c10
are domestic fraternal societies orders
and associations under the lodge system
now
my question is related to the ir
the inner
internal revenue codes classifications
for tax exempt organizations and my
question
to representative ulri is what makes
these three new sub
groups special because that we know that
there are other non-exempt or tax-exempt
organizations
that could also technically
be included if we are going to expand
the definition
so my question is why not c4s civic
leagues why not c5s agricultural groups
and labor organizations
why not c6
chambers of commerce for instance or the
nfl
why not c7
recreational clubs why not c9 voluntary
employment benefit associations
why not c10 teachers retirement fund
associations and why not c-12s the
benevolent life associations
very good i'd like the amendment that
you're suggesting that anyone registered
with the irs under a 501c category thank
you
uh well it wasn't my recommendation but
um my question
i smell on that question to you
why why are these sub groups more
special than the rest
why not be treating everyone the same
because i'm familiar with the ones i
listed and i'm not that familiar with an
thank you
um mr chair uh
uh president obama have a question uh
hold on a minute
end up
you see it was down that's why i chimed
in
yes i took my hand down thank you okay
uh representative brownlee
yeah thank you uh mr chair uh
representative
and rsa287a
colon one
uh
what is the definition of a raffle
how broad is that
well that's something we need to look up
and
you know is it i mean
i don't know if it's what is the actual
definition
i should have gone out of time but i
mean off the top of your head
i
i've got another uh
bill coming up on uh expanding the uh
balance of that and that's within the
raffle definition but right now the
definition of a raffle is limited into a
mount uh and it's a ticket that is sold
to the public as opposed to a 50 50
which is sold within a closed
environment
follow-up i was going to ask if
5050 was included in this
no that's
generally since it's not 5050s are not
generally uh sold to the public but
they're you know uh you have a uh
a pta meeting and everyone within the
pta throws in there 50 cents and gets a
ticket and then they split it 50 50
whatever within the within a limited
group that is present then and there
it's not uh offered to the public
normally
and that is a
yeah so follow up so 5050 is not
included in this
right not included yeah thank you
any further questions in the from the
llb
all set in the lb well okay
i just i just raised my question to my
hand again
representative ames
okay representatives
sorry to go back and forth um
so um this amendment would
add three
501c
subsets
to
the current 501c3 that's the way i
understand it
my question
is
can you tell us offhand or
do we need to
flush it out ourselves
what restrictions
apply to 501c3s
in terms of
activity
compliance with particular rules
whatever
uh
that do not apply to the other subsets
that uh this bill would add
uh to this
to the list of uh
entities authorized to
take part in these other charitable
gaming activities
uh i'm really that that's a question
that someone in your profession uh would
better answer the irs classification c
distinctions
of
purpose and activity in which the entity
is engaged
for example the knights of columbus the
knights of pythius sell insurance to the
foresters uh sell insurance
to their members
therefore their 501c8
the masons is a large organization
they're set up as 501 c 10s uh from my
understanding on discussing uh this with
the the attack of the
attorneys that i deal with
um
in the knights of columbus it's very
simple to
is only a
administrative division of charitable
organizations but they're not being
called charities also uh contributions
to the knights or to the masons are not
themselves deductible as a tax entity
whereas uh
contributions to 501c3
are tax deductible it's you know it's
it's it's
into
um
the weeds on law and that but uh
as far as i i understand it it's there's
just subtle differences like that 501 c
as uh
representative hocken phillips just said
was uh
educational with uh
a lot of subsections that goes on for
pages and pages and pages but
uh the opportunity by putting 501 c2s in
there was to
allow schools to do these things
directly
and
the others to do them directly as well
one thing that has come out of this
testimony so far is that if we were to
strike all of those and just say
registered with the irs is a 501c entity
and that would cover
any existing in any future uh
not-for-profit organizations that are
registered with the irs but not
necessarily registered with the
secretary of state
okay follow-up
thought
yeah well i think this is an important
question we need to know for sure what
the uh restrictions uh
are that apply to these different
subsets because uh we need to go into
this with our eyes open um and uh i i
guess i'm going to
say that we
i want i want to have a uh
and i'll work on it myself if nobody
else will uh but maybe representative
hack and phillips can help
to get a full full explanation of the
differences
um
as we jump from
just one subset of 501c to
four
excellent questions
uh
further question
are you all set representative ames
i am thank you
thank you for uh uh taking my question i
uh
i'm
curious to know if
when uh we capture all those uh
nonprofits
uh this may not be relevant but do any
of those include political organizations
that raise money for the purpose of
lobbying um
i just don't know and and i was just
curious if that
scoops up
the uh that kind of thing too thank you
yes thank you uh uh representative
malloy and yes you're correct uh i
the the list is is long and
extensive on that and i agree with the
representative aims that a short uh
break to discuss all of the 501 c
bs would be
uh very appropriate
and yes uh a political entity is
included as a 501c not
non-tax entity i had forgotten about
that thank you
thank you mr chair yeah i do think that
there are certain regulations related to
some political and lobbying activities
for any of these charitable
organizations um i think the threshold
is about 18
of their income
can be allocated to those activities
without losing their tax exempt status
so i think you might run the risk of um
well if if the organizations aren't
careful in monitoring that
activity and raffles become
a political and some nature that they
could be running the risk of losing
their status it's just
um
it's dependent upon the activity itself
so i think this becomes a real gray area
and you know definitely further
discussion about this would be helpful i
think
would you say that again please
sure i mean so 501c organizations that
fall under the category of c3 are
limited to how much
activity they can allocate their income
towards that may be political or
lobbying in nature
before they're in um danger of losing
their tax-exempt status
so um you know
whether or not a raffle could qualify as
an activity as political or lobbying
could
you know affect their status but in
terms of being able to raffle i don't
think that that
would have any significance but it's
worth that you know diving in deeper to
find out
um you know how raffle might qualify as
political or or a lobbying activity
any response to that reps in your league
no i i agree that uh uh
thankful for in
that the discussion thus far has
brought out some issues that uh
uh unfortunately
attorneys uh like to pull out but uh
thank the
members for uh bringing those out and uh
if you
feel that we should discuss this a
little bit further that's fine i would
be happy to work with
a subcommittee on addressing those
it's best to pull them out now rather
than
get clobbered late later
thank you mr chairman on
i want to just raise the issue of
enforcement of
raffles i presume that we have raffles
in our law because there were a bunch of
unscrupulous people in the past that
on raised money saying that on
you're going to win a
chevrolet
impala or something like that
and then there was no chevrolet impala
or nobody ever won
except the guy that had the raffle
and
so there must be some
some method of enforcement which i'm
afraid would just be the ag's office and
which is so overworked that it doesn't
do any consumer enforcement usually
um
and i'm wondering on what
expanding whether they would be uh
upset
at being handed more of this or not
um whether we want to take a look at
whether we need some other kind of
enforcement for raffles if we're going
to expand it or even if we leave it the
uh representative welmy already the
raffle is pretty well controlled by
lottery
they they monitor these things we
require separate checkbooks uh
have people going out and checking the
checkbooks now and again i'm familiar
with organizations that do bingo and
such like activities i don't think this
would be an expansion of the enforcement
effort as for how the laws came into
effect i don't think it was a chevrolet
impala i think it was a herd of goats
was the first raffle or something like
that
um it's
you know it's just a human activity of
uh trying to make money off of some
other people or or have a good social
time um
at a dinner dance or something like that
to
raise money for a good cause i know
there are
some raffles with limited ticket sales
that uh
provide scholarships for uh students uh
that provide uh aid for uh
uh dependent children uh eight for unwed
mothers if you will or single parents um
you know the the entire gamut and it's
you know
you just want to make sure that everyone
can offer those that that uh
wish to to
continue to do good works i was the uh
principal behind this thank you can we
be very for the rest of this
representative elliot
yeah mr chairman uh
is my hearing correct
did
representative jewelry withdraw the bill
no
okay
jordan
yes
okay
mr chairman i was trying to get a
follow-up
thank you
um
the i think that representative hillary
is talking about lottery overseeing
these in bingo games and things like
that the first uh raffle
on after i came back to this country
that i saw on in the market day of
hanover on was a group that seemed that
didn't deal with it
apparently was picking up
on names of people to use for some other
purpose
on and raffling something off in a booth
fair
and they did not appear the next time i
think hanover closed them down but on
the
i was on
if we open it up like this on
we
we do run the risk of going back to that
kind of
of raffle and
i was hoping that we could follow this
up with the
lottery as well as the ag's office do
they really go
have any control over any lotteries
other than the one i mean uh raffles and
other than the ones that uh
are attached to charitable gaming
let me say something now
this bill isn't going to pass as is
normally if we were in
regular session
we would
put this bill into a subcommittee
to be worked on because it needs
a lot more answers
well
we're operating in a different
environment
so we're going to be taking
we're going to have a work session on
the bill and determine
are we going to retain it are we going
to
try to get amendments that would satisfy
all of our questions
or not so
we will have a work session so
we can get some of those answers at that
point in time
we have one other hand that i see raised
and then i'd like to go to the blue
sheet
representative fred de set
there's one in attendees as well okay
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
clarify something because i've heard
that the words charitable gaming banted
around a little bit in this conversation
we do have some other legislation we'll
be considering today this in no way
shape or form
uh expands charitable gaming this is
specific to
uh raffles
so i just wanted that to be clear and
and confirm that with uh with the
sponsor
okay
any comments from the sponsor
no that's that was the the uh idea
john king is in the panelists
okay
hi this is mallory king with new
hampshire lottery can you hear me
yes
hi i just wanted to clarify that um the
lottery does not regulate raffles it is
regulated by the city or town in which
the raffle is being drawn
we do have raffles that can be sold at
bingo but again we don't regulate those
raffles they're just allowed at the
bingo game thank you
thank you
miss chair one more thing uh service
secretary
uh the thing that's surprising to me is
that
we're talking you know the title of bill
is
fraternal organization
you know i would think that photographer
organizations do raffles already
but
i guess i'm wrong
uh i guess the question is are are
are there total organizations now that
are doing raffles not knowing that it's
it's not in the statutes for them to do
that
that's for the sponsor
right
that's my feeling too so we're going to
make honest people with everybody if we
if we bless this
uh more honest than they are as far as i
know uh raffles that are run by some of
the entities are
already approved by the town in which
the drawing takes place and that is in
statue
i i i not it's not clear area for me
which is one of the uh
executive
so that's helpful because we're trying
to clarify
[Music]
hey representative romney
is there something
you can do with your audio because
you're breaking up
yeah i'm too close to the microphone
how's that
that's better yeah
um are we all set representative
brownlee because
we're on
set
okay
on the blue sheet we have
three people that signed up
two in support and one neutral
the support was representative part
check
and
a member from the public george
carl melis
then
one that's neutral with the bill eric
rockman
does there anybody else want to speak
in opposition or support of the bill
then
i'm going to close the public hearing on
house bill 364
and i will be starting the public
hearing
[Music]
well if you want to go against these
codes
yeah you know we're going to have to see
what's what's wrong with these codes
right
i have a sense where don't swallow i
just want to retain it just
ah
are we delaying starting again
okay
so i had a phone call for four of those
i guess i have to unmute myself
okay i guess we can start the public
hearing on house bill 565.
565 is an act establishing a committee
to study charitable gaming
and this is uh crime sponsors
representative ames
representative ames i want to introduce
yes and thank you
so it's my privilege to
introduce for consideration by this
committee house bill 565.
um
i should i think i'll start with uh with
this that
the bill is sponsored by democrats i
regret that it's only democrats i
thought that it would be otherwise
and expected that there would be
republican participation on this it was
certainly developed as a bipartisan bill
and i hope it will be
seen as such and dealt with as such as
we go forward
and
let's hope so
okay
i'm going to run through a quick sketch
of the bill
and then give you some history
uh
from which it springs and uh
and uh then talk about what we might do
with it um
so the bill itself
calls for setting up a
study committee a legislative study
committee with three house members and
two
senate members
um
and uh the focus of the
work of this committee would be
uh is all spelled out there starting at
line
11 and ending at line
24 of the bill
um
four important
issues would be addressed
first would be looking at the oversight
and enforcement of charitable gaming in
new hampshire
and how
the regulatory structure that we have
including staffing levels
compares with best practice
regulatory standards for the gaming
industry
and to regulatory structures used in
other jurisdictions the second
duty of the committee would be to review
the recommendations of prior study
commissions
with respect to the regulatory structure
of charitable gaming
and uh look at
how well or badly the recommendations
coming out of those prior study
commissions have been addressed
and the third category looks at the
revenues
generated by
charitable gaming operators in the state
and the check and the amount distributed
to charities
served by that operator
including cost considerations
duty of this commission
is to study the selection look at the
selection of charities by charitable
gaming operators
um
and uh so that's the that's the focus of
the this proposed study
um
and the report the other important
point is that the report of the
committee if we were to go forward with
this
would be due honor before november
okay so a little bit of history i think
might be helpful
um
back when i first entered the
legislature in 2012
i very quickly got involved because i
was a member of this committee committee
in a
massive effort to develop a uh
a
super large casino
in new hampshire and uh
and that activity led to my appointment
to
serve as chair of
a new new hampshire gaming regulatory
commission in
2013.
that commission
did did work it was funded
at a consultant and
developed
a very lengthy detailed report and two
bills
one of which was for expanded gaming
which would be the casino
and the other bill
was for reform
in charitable gaming
the
bills
were put into the hopper in
and the expanded gaming bill
failed in the house by one vote if i
remember correctly
a close call and the
other bill on expanded charitable gaming
passed
both bodies and was enacted into the law
with essentially no change from
the form that it
took uh coming out of the
this gaming commission
and that is what we now have
in
284 a
rsa284a
is essentially what was put into
law as a product of this work of course
it's been demanded a little bit
uh betting limits uh
for form certain forms of gambling have
been
uh raised and a few changes have been
made but essentially is the same there
was one more big change that was made
in uh i think it was 2015 and in the
budget
and that was to
bring under the bring into the lottery
commission the duties of what was then
uh before that
a separate entity the racing and
charitable gaming commission
so uh lottery took over those functions
and took over the duties and
and task of implementing overseeing
doing was called for by this
new 284
a
so that's the background
it was a massive effort to perform to
enhan enhance oversight
of
charitable gaming it included provisions
that
focused on
sort of the black market game gaming in
new hampshire and enhanced
the powers of the attorney general
as well as of lottery with respect to
those activities in fact one of the
bills that we have this year
the other number is uh
i i can't pull it up i guess uh
one of one of our pending bills
uh would create a division of
enforcement within the lottery it's sort
of consistent with this
this uh effort that i'm describing
so uh why go forward with this bill now
um
my my thoughts about it are that
years have passed since that
major change in structure and
scope of regulatory activity
nature of uh regulation and so forth
um
[Music]
time has gone by since that was enacted
it's isn't that time to take a look at
it
and see how it's doing whether it's
sufficient or
should be modified and i i think that
should be done
particularly since we're seeing
so much
interest in expanding charitable gaming
let's be sure that we've got a structure
and oversight system that ensures that
gambling in new hampshire which
history tells us can couldn't can can go
wrong
uh it goes right as we go forward
um that's my motivation for
refiling it i guess another motivation
is that i was deeply involved in this
at that time and helped to create this
thing and uh you know i'm not going to
be around forever so i'd uh i'd like to
see uh
have some assurance that we're going
down the right path and not the wrong
path
in terms of uh
going forward with this bill
i'd like to say that
i think it's important to do this i
think it's really important
but it's got to be done with
with conviction and by
with the participation of both parties
gambling and oversight of gambling
in my experience in this legislature has
been bipartisan that fight over the
expanded gaming
was very much a fight that mixed up
parties i got to know a whole lot of
people that i wouldn't have gotten to
know really well
as i came down on the side of pushing
for expanded gaming
and i uh
really appreciated the relationships
that uh
grew out of that
and so uh if we're going to go forward
with this committee
um i know it's hard to do this kind of
thing in the time of cobin but uh
maybe uh
we can find a way of doing it i hope we
can go forward with it and uh so i'll
leave it that leave it at that
thank you mr chair would you mind if i
chimed in first uh president brownie
go ahead representative romney
thank you representative ames uh
so you know there's a companion bill
over in the senate you may be aware of
that very similar bill
representative uh senator dallas
seinfeld actually reached out to me and
asked if i sent out as a sponsor or
co-sponsor which i did
if i don't know if you would email me i
would have certainly signed on as a
co-sponsor in this bill so
there's definitely bipartisan uh support
for continue review
the study that you talked about from
several years ago
it was a commission then um i'm assuming
we're talking about the same one
it was a senate bill though uh that i
think created it
um
yeah dick you want to respond to that i
think it was a thing yeah i didn't hear
a word you said it
so
there's a there's a similar bill over in
the senate right now
yeah yeah yeah you aware of that
yeah okay so i i i think they do the
same thing
uh obviously we'll we'll merge the bills
together i'm a co-sponsor of that bill
senator alessandro had reached out to me
oh uh we'll definitely be bipartisan
in this uh i would have signed on this
bill i didn't i didn't even know this
bill was being filed
uh so
but i was also involved in the
commission it was five or six years ago
and i'm i'm just wondering if that that
was the same committee it was a it
wasn't a committee it wasn't a joint
committee
it was a commission that included uh
others uh remember there was state
police was on it there was somebody from
the ag's office on it
uh that we
i think that's the commission that uh
that you're talking about from years ago
that you were incorporating in the bill
here
uh for us to review and to update uh
some of those recommendations from them
uh
clearly then the only thing i'll point
out to the committee
is that
uh that then and i think representative
ames mentioned this then it was under
the
auspices of
of uh the gerald gaming commission they
had their own commission and a few years
ago we wrapped that into that commission
went away
and so charitable gaming is now under
the auspices of lottery
and uh i think lottery
uh was a better place for it to be
honest with you
so but i don't want to give background i
was involved uh so as we we worked this
bill
uh i'm in full support of it dick uh
and uh
it doesn't hurt
to ensure we we had our concerns back
then
uh about about the oversight
uh and i think it's time i agree i think
it's time to take another look
at how we're doing now that lottery is
in control of it
so
may i respond
yes yes
thank you that was good to hear um
and uh i would just say that regarding
the history
i think there may have been two
commissions um
the commission that uh i was referring
to was uh
a funded commission and it
it had had the directive lottery on it
the attorney general was on it
personally as a matter of fact the
crafters of that bill for some reason
didn't allow him to designate anyone
so
the attorney general was on there
personally the lottery director was on
there the commissioner of public safety
was on there senator rausch republican
senator roush was
was an active participant i worked
closely with him
and
there were others
a very very good hard-working commission
and i do think and this is another
reason why we should
should do this uh that there was a
separate an additional effort looking at
charitable gaming that came a year or
two later
yeah that's yes you're correct that's
the commission i'm talking about that
was focused just on charitable gain
yeah so i guess i'm very familiar with
the commission you were on and then
there was another one that was was the
senate bill that created it
and i i was picked and i was the two
legislators on that with me uh from the
house and senator alessandro from the
senate
and uh and that we should access that
report if this passes
we should see what that report said
going you know way back
great
uh before we go to any cr any questions
i just do have one question
on the membership
is why is it
you know i think five would be better
representative major um
[Music]
three makes choosing difficult and uh
and five uh maybe we could reach out to
uh
people outside of the ways and means
committee it was just three
so you wouldn't have any problem expect
i would have no problem going to five
representative
thank you mr chair
uh
thank you for bringing that forward
that's i i was uh unaware that
existed and
would be happy to work with uh
with representative ames
representative tucker
yes i just wanted to say that that was
enormously useful to hear the history
um
seeing the bill by itself uh when i read
it over i didn't understand the
background
and i do think bipartisanship on this
essential
and i think your explanation
made it highly more likely
i
although i understand the senate
is apparently
considering such a bill it sounds like
they are going to be much more under the
gun to
roll up their bills into sort of
uh
conglomerations and i hope you
continue to keep this going
and that's what you believe right
representative
means
thank you mr chairman
um
representative ames i was just wondering
is it currently true that charitable
charitable gaming operators have
complete control over who they choose as
charities
well
that's a good question i i think
there's a lot of discretion
given to the
gaming operators and
not much in the way of uh limitations
but you know that's one of the things
that's it's exactly one of the things
i'd like to to look closely at exactly
thank you
yeah i'm going to be answering i'm 900
sure but uh
i know that uh
charlie's going to be here for the one
o'clock hearing on the historic racing
bill
and that's a good time to ask that
question
uh in that bill we're going to expand
the number of charities that are going
to be allowed to participate because
there's a very long list of charities
that want to get involved right now
so
but that'll be this afternoon but
charlie will be there the whole meeting
thank you i just wanted to respond to
that as somebody who's actually been on
a non-profit fundraising committee
i used to run nonprofits and had to
actually do this
their every
charitable gaming location has you fill
out an application
and then they tell you what dates you
have
you only get 10 dates in a year in a
calendar year
and they do not let you pick your dates
they do tell you so i do believe it's
actually quite selective but yes um
i believe that um director mcintyre
would be obviously expert but
um if you have any questions i'm happy
to tell you from a outsider's
mr chairman i'm a co-sponsor so i'm just
hoping to be able to say something as
testimony after everybody else's talk
okay thank you uh actually i just wanted
to
to point out that the senate has said
that it's not doing
uh i think openly that they're not doing
study committees this year at all and
that
the house i believe the speaker had
indicated that we shouldn't be doing
them either
and i was thinking that this might go
into
uh
retention but
it is so um
on all embracing that except for it
doesn't have the uh treatment for
problem gamblers how that's working and
that's subject i'd love to know more
about
on
i wonder if representative ames would be
uh would think that it could be done in
retention
or if the chair can say something about
it
this is important
and there's no reason we can't do it
if we're doing public hearings and
executive sessions
on
virtually
we can do this directly
okay
so could we do it as a retained bill
because if we send it over to the senate
i think it gets
killed it may end up being a retained
bill but let's
we're going to have a work session first
so let's think about it
and
what's the best way of addressing that
in this environment
mr chair if you don't mind me and uh
representative romney if the senate says
they don't want to do care uh
commissions the next or even joint
committees
next year
then we can make this bill uh just a a
committee of the house
and then we have to worry about the
senate but we prefer to have the
senators involved but
that's one optional term
i can make an ad hoc committee
yeah but yeah because as a bill it would
so you got a little support
[Laughter]
yes thank you uh would you believe uh
representative ames that in that uh
uh representative gorg's uh statement
there is accurate and uh important to uh
what she said about the uh the the
non-profits and her analysis of how you
apply for that and the to be a
non-profit to be on the list of
that's what you believe representative
[Music]
am i supposed to respond to that well
my my point is that's a very important
part of this and i would ask you
uh
would we concentrate on that issue of
how these charities
uh apply
to get in line
for uh
as a part of your structure here and
analyze how charities get in line for
charitable uh contributions chairman
yeah i guess i i should respond to that
i think that's a very important issue
it's not the only issue and the other
issues i've sketched out there sketched
out in this legislation so
um absolutely this needs to be looked at
um
yeah i'll just leave it there okay
anybody else wish to testify
for or against
house bill 565 and do we have anybody
representative major i have peter
bragdon in the attendees that asked to
speak
okay would you
unmute him
yeah there he goes okay thank you uh mr
chairman and uh members of committee um
for the record my name is peter bragdon
i represent churchill downs incorporated
here to speak in favor of house bill
565.
as many of you know churchill downs is
home to the kentucky derby a race often
called the most exciting two minutes in
sports the kentucky derby is the longest
continually held sporting event in
america having been run continuously
since 1875.
that'll be 146 years uh this coming may
churchill downs is more than a famous
racetrack however churchill downs is a
publicly traded company operating 10
gaming facilities in nine states
these are clean modern facilities
featuring electronic and table gaming
the same types of games we see in new
hampshire's casinos
i'll actually be testifying later today
on your one o'clock bill on historic
racing but i thought i would comment on
this bill as well
churchill downs knows that a strong
regulatory environment is important to
the entire gaming community
if something goes awry at one facility
it affects public confidence statewide
and perhaps nationwide this is even more
important with charitable gaming because
people want to be sure the money is
going to the charities and not sneaking
out the back door
at the public hearing on representative
abrami's bill to create a new division
of investigation and compliance
rick newman stated the number one item
of importance in any gambling operation
is integrity churchill downs agrees with
that statement
you talked
a little bit about the provision of the
bill that asks to review recommendations
of prior study committees as i looked
through the legislature's archives of
study committees um i found a couple of
reports both of which representative
ames and romney have mentioned two
separate reports one was the final
report of the gaming regulatory
oversight committee from 2013 that's the
one that representative ames chaired
uh and i urge committee members if you
get a chance pull down those reports and
take a look at them there they're
eye-opening uh in the 2013 report on
pages
36-39 refers to quote significant
deficiencies in the existing charitable
gaming regulatory system
it notes that the state only has three
field investigators these are the people
who watch the games and the back office
operations to make sure the games and
the facilities are running compliance
with state regulations and thus
make sure the charities receive all that
is due them
that report says there's three field
investigators to watch over over close
to 300 gambling tables in 12 locations
across the state from berlin to the
seacoast to the connecticut river in
addition to 300 bingo and lucky seven
licensees
three people to do that the 2013 report
calls that a significant deficiency
then there was a 2015 report the one
that which uh representative abrami sat
on the final report of the games for
charity study committee and these are
all happening back in the days i was
hanging around the senate too by the way
i apologize for any bad behavior with
the senate with respect to study
committees
um my past sins
that 2015 report contains repeated
warnings about the lack of staff to
oversee charitable gaming activity in
new hampshire
it notes that two years after the prior
report we're pointing out there's only
three field investigators to cover the
entire state there is still only three
field investigators to cover the entire
state
the recommendation from that 2015 report
was to bring on three more full-time
field investigators and a dozen or more
part-timers you know as you know these
facilities they're open late in the
evening they're open on weekends they're
open on holidays uh and in this type of
situation a locally based part-timer is
probably more
than
full-timers traveling across the state
and spending all their time in cars
i checked and in november of 2020 so
five years after this report and seven
years after the first report we still
only have three full-time field
inspectors plus they did add one
part-time and they made one a supervisor
but only three full-time field
inspectors and one part-timer five years
after it was
cited as a significant deficiency
back then i'm going to guess the total
amount of money bet um
terrible gaming operations and table
games and such was probably around 200
million dollars at one o'clock you're
going to hear a bill that will add at
least according to last year's fiscal
note
550 million dollars of cash flowing into
a system
of 750 million dollars three times what
it was in 2015 when we decided for not
having enough people to keep an eye on
things
um the report states that terrible
gaming is a system that can quote if
left unattended serve the charities less
and private interests more
it says quote charities are at the mercy
of those individuals into whose hands
the charity has entrusted their gaming
receipts often with poor results for the
charity
and it closes with this recommendation
before any discussion of expanding
charitable gaming there must be a commit
commitment by the state to adequately
fund the positions necessary for
oversight and enforcement to ensure the
integrity of the games and to preserve
the very important resources resources
the charities that the system provides
the report mentions of audit of the
coaching valley humane society a 2013
audit discovered that in a one year
period
twenty thousand dollars of proceeds were
unaccounted for
plus there was ninety thousand dollars
of unapproved and unreported free play
awarded and twenty thousand dollars of
questionable expenses
that's a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars of potentially missing proceeds
for a charity in a one-year period
that's more than twice the amount of
money the charity actually received
for the operations
so again i suggest these prior reports
will provide good background reading for
committee members and in closing i
repeat churchill downs supports a strong
regulatory environment a strong
regulatory environment increases public
trust and more importantly ensures that
money is supposed to be go that is
supposed to be going to charities is
indeed going to the charities and not
slipping out the back door for that
reason churchill down supports hb 565
and urges an ought to pass
recommendation i thank you for your time
i'd be happy to answer any questions you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
bragdon for your testimony
um i'm kind of curious as to why
churchill
downs has such an interest in the
regulatory nature and enforcement
of charitable gaming rooms in the state
of new hampshire maybe you can explain
that with some clarity for me
sure thank you for the question
representative as i mentioned you know
churchill downs is more than a racetrack
we operate 10 gaming facilities in nine
states uh constantly looking for
opportunities that may arise and
obviously as i pointed out and last year
testified as well
um you know looking for opportunities
that come up and in this case um the one
o'clock bill was the more interesting
one but this one really you know it's
foundational
right there's so much money flowing in
it has to be kept track of in order to
protect the charities so churchill downs
is interested in opportunities that may
come up um
and new hampshire's a state that they've
had their eye on
uh i guess we didn't get to the point
that i thought you'd take care mr
bragdon
uh
churchill downs is the owner operator of
the oxford casino in maine correct
that is
correct and maybe you could tell us what
the the
revenues or the total receipts say last
year for oxford casino was
um
thank you representative i have no idea
what that cannot hear him sorry guys
can you speak up
mr brighton
oh i'm sorry um i have no idea what the
revenues are for the oxford casino okay
well i'm i'm
i'm guessing there's probably a
percentage of those dollars that come
from the state of new hampshire so
i guess your your concern about or not
so much your concern but the concern of
churchill downs
in the operation and enforcement of
charitable gaming in new hampshire would
probably have an effect on the bottom
line
over an oxford
oxford casino or am i mistaken
representative i really have no idea not
only what the revenues in oxford are or
from whence they come i do know that
churchill downs operates in nine states
and would be interested in operating
more
okay so
follow up
so i
so can you testify that if
in fact
new hampshire charitable gaming and the
charities that are served by charitable
gaming
succeed in new hampshire
is that a revenue loss for churchill
downs
in the oxford maine casino
so we're in competition now the
charities are in competition the state
of new hampshire is in competition with
your client churchill downs is what i'm
is that saying
former question
yes
are they in competition
sorry mr chair
thank you representative and again i
have no idea what the breakdown is of
play at the oxford casino in oxford
maine
but i do know that churchill downs
operates in nine different states and is
always looking opportunities to operate
in others and should they operate
you know hypothetically in new hampshire
um to the degree that's competing with
what they do in maine my feeling as a
businessman was always it's better to
compete with myself than to compete with
someone else so i think they'd be
looking for
the opportunity if it presented itself
in a favorable way
i thank you mr chair i very much look
forward to your testimony on uh house
representative
thank you mr chairman uh since i'm a
co-sponsor i want to word this as would
the committee please ask for
representative
senator uh
bragdon's uh
testimony
there was a lot of material in there
that i for one have never heard before
and it would be good to be able to go
back and check the reports and
think about the numbers thank you
verizon can you provide us with a copy
of your testimony yes represent romney
and uh chairman major i'd be happy to
submit that in writing
thank you
chair of
representatives to ask a question
representative romney
yes thank you senator bradley bragging
for your testimony
uh
i think the biggest problem that our
commission dealt with was
the fact that
that
we try to add positions
to the lottery
that those somehow don't make it through
finance
and that's the biggest obstacle that we
all have to deal with is
how do we convince
because that would that would reduce the
amount of
monies going to the education trust fund
uh because you know it's net of expense
so if we had three or four more people
which we didn't recommend
uh we're always faced with finance
looking for money and you you know being
seeing senate president
you know what i'm talking about
uh i think
uh so
that's that's if you have any ideas or
suggestions for how to convince the
legislature that this is an important
matter
being former senate president
uh thank you representative romney for
the question and i will point out the
report definitely says these are things
that need to be done yet it is in some
ways beyond the control of the lottery
commission and i certainly don't want to
imply that the lottery commission
um
there's fundamental flaws if you do
the reports all indicate it's a matter
of resources and in terms of
uh convincing the finance committees
that these are things to be supportive i
think you know
maybe one way is to focus on the
potential downsides take a look at that
one particular charity that
although they made 70 000
in a year
um from the operations that they had
there was another 130 000
that
was unaccounted for
and so again we want to make sure i
think we're all concerned in new
hampshire about our charities and making
sure they get what is due especially in
these tough
economic times that we're in
and so i think the focus really needs to
be
that um if if something goes wrong right
if something goes wrong it'll
uh put the whole system into a mode of
suspicion and actually might hurt
everybody across the board so i do i do
understand uh representative uh in a way
more than most i suppose that haven't
served in the legislature
the difficulties of navigating the
financial piece as well as the policy
any further questions
zen
thank you for your testimony
okay i don't see any other hands raised
but i have a pink sheet here
and the paint sheet shows that we have
in support of the bill
but none of these people want to testify
and support is a heidi hammer
season like
so represented
and
opposed
is nolan granville
who's a member of the public
support
jerry stringham was was a former member
of the
razor means there's a member of the
public now
and our position is a daniel richardson
a member of the public
does anybody else wish to support
rooster testify in support or opposition
to
saying none i'm going to close the
as i
had mentioned earlier we had planned to
do some
exacting on about five bills
but because
we heard this morning
that the governor's budget is going to
be provided to the legislature at
noontime today it's going to consist of
the reduction in business enterprise
business process tax rates
the
[Music]
interest and dividend tax also reduction
in the males and rooms tax
we will not be taken up at this point in
time
house bill 10
so
this house bill
306.
now 306 is an amendment
everybody
everybody received the amendment on
house bill 306
if you haven't
indicate
as if if you don't have the amendment
representative hacking phillips we have
not received it i can't find it i
thought i saw it come across and i
looked for it this morning again and i
couldn't locate it does anyone know when
and we get it put up on i have a copy of
it ready if
there was a way for me to do that
jane can you put a copy of
that's
can you put a copy of the amendment
for house bill 306.
i'm one of the ones that can't find it
either
so
with all of those other huge numbers of
people saying that they want more money
so
is there a way i could put it up
jennifer's jennifer's there
you do have permission representative me
you're muted
there's no way to take it from gallery
no because that's a controller
[Music]
okay i'm trying to
to get both that and the screen up at
the same time so
just give me a second here
yeah i had had it sitting there so i
could look at it
that's too small right so let me go up a
bit
great
mr chairman would you talk to it or
would you like me to talk to it
why don't you go ahead
okay
the
what this takes out
they rewrote it instead of of doing the
taking out parts
on
number one
roman one in the original bill
says that on
if the unrestricted revenue estimate
should be
while operating under the emergency
executive orders issued in response to
the coven 19 pandemic and after the
orders expire
and then goes on in the original two
to say the estimate will be based on
current law and economic conditions and
shall be updated regularly throughout fy
21 2
and 3 to reflect current conditions and
economic forecasts
and
what
i did to that
actually i took out current conditions
and economic forecasts the second time
but um
what i did instead was to take out while
operating under emergency executive
orders
and
the
uh
specification of fiscal years one two
and three 21 22 and 23
and leave the rest of it there
and i wish that they'd done it that way
so that you could see it but they didn't
uh
and the
reason for that is that this is
something we've always done the chair
has always decided when there was
something tricky going on in the economy
that could affect our revenues
or
on a major bill had been passed that
upset our revenues
uh in the second year when it was
effective
the chair would call
the committee together to look at
revenue estimates again
or at least the part of it that they
thought was affected
and on sometimes the agencies for both
of us have been
on
have been reluctant to go through the
process again and have wanted to hold to
the numbers that were
were
put into the budget
on
and
i believe that
the chair's
reason for putting this still in
was to
to overcome the cha the
agency's reluctance to participate
on it at least gives a stimulus to them
to participate
that we have something in law we have
never had the process of revenue
estimates in law
on
since they were started in 1971
and i know that because i was given the
entire history when i became chair by
the then clerk of the house
and
um
it's
this would be the first part that would
be in law and i did not want to see it
go in as something that we were only
doing for three years because then the
agencies would say
say
but
and on representative major agreed with
me about that and asked me to bring in a
trial amendment and here it is
alemay did an excellent job in
modifying this bill
because it is very important
not only
because we all know
that the economic situation can change
dramatically with
without any warning such as the pandemic
or other other type of disasters
so this gives us the ability that it's
codified now in statute that we can do
this
even though uh in the past there's times
we've done it
and the speaker
would go along with it but there's been
times that i've wanted to
redo the revenue estimates
and i've been told not to
and
my feeling is and i think it should be
the feeling in the ways and means if the
economic conditions change
we have an obligation
to update the revenues
let's say if they
were reduced
to warn the finance committee to warn
the executive branch
that the revenues aren't going to be
there and start taking action
if we don't do this they won't know
this
and so we would actually be doing our
that's all i have to add to that
any
representative tucker has her hand up
represented tucker
i
yes
i can't find the reference but i
actually have been reading the kefir
and
there are occasions in that where
i think under tobacco tax for example
it says that the agency will be looking
every quarter
so i think you need a phrase that says
notwithstanding
other references or something
and so maybe that's why there's been a
difference between the agency's view
because they
you know
they have it built into their system
that even though it isn't in the statute
that they will do whatever you so often
and so we need to make sure that there
isn't a conflict there and i wish i
could
find the reference it'll
but we have a time to take it up i think
it's really important that we be able to
i'm not going to be able to find the
that's a big document
so i'm not going to be able to find
uh
i'm i'm sorry i don't seem to be able to
raise my hand while i'm i'm sharing a
screen
but on
i
i believe
i don't think this would be a problem
but maybe we should
i don't know if we need to ask the
comptroller on
but
that is a regulation but also when we do
do this
on we usually don't try to force the
agency to tell us what the
this the last month has has done if they
had to do a complicated calculation
three months ago
by their own
regulations
right maybe that takes care of it
i do think it's very important when
things are unexpected that we're able to
respond
i think we could work around that but we
and
that's a major i i can see
representative ames has his hand up i
think that's all the hands
[Music]
okay well wait a minute
yeah i think i'm unmuted
yes
okay uh
so yeah this is an excellent change i i
was uh quite concerned with the
original version of the bill because i
i thought that it once the emergency
passes this particular emergency passes
the
implication of the bill would be that
somehow the ways and means committee
no long would no longer have the
power the ability to
do
estimates as economic conditions changed
so this makes it clear that we have that
authority i think i actually think that
we already have it but dive agencies are
recalcitrant as has been reported by
both representatives almighty and major
and they should know if anyone knows
that history
then i think this is a very good thing
to put into the statutes and uh
yeah uh
this is well for representative me but i
support the bill i support the amendment
um
but for representative tucker each
mentions tobacco
as one area that
if i heard it correctly but that
tobacco's on the department of revenue
um and i can't recall anytime that we've
asked department of revenue to help us
out and do something that it was an
issue
is
it was am i correct in hearing about
representative tucker that it was in
tobacco that you saw this or was it the
ag's
uh the tobacco uh settlement
thanks
sorry i muted myself yes it was under
tobacco it wasn't under the settlement
it just would be a phrase but
if it's not necessary it's not necessary
it'll be good
but i think it's very important that we
have this
kind of amendment
yeah
what one what this also does
we can go to the floor and update the
house resolution
and as
as the economic conditions dictate
and then with the house resolution
it will deviate
from what the
revenues are in the budget because the
revenues that are in the budget is
what's passed
the committee of compromise between the
housing
and the
and the senate
that will always be in the budget but
this will warn them
hey their evidence aren't going to be
like we thought they were going to be in
june
any further questions or comments on
this
then
um
session on house bill 306.
thank you mr chairman i would like to
make a motion to
uh for ought to pass for hb 306 and then
another motion for the amendment
when i can
that second
absolutely makes the motion about the
we have a
motion for an amendment
uh yes uh i move
amendment
uh 3 18 h
to
house bill 306
that's ought to pass that's out to pass
my second motion
saying then normally
if we were in house session we could
raise our hands
but all votes have to be taken by a roll
call
so there's no further any further
discussion
since no further discussion with the
clerk call the role
and i suggest that uh representative
mommy take down the uh on the amendment
oh that would be good yes
on could i suggest on this is on the
amendment yes yes on the amendment
318h
okay um mr chair just a clarification
is there two votes or are we just voting
on them
votes one on the amendment and then one
okay this is on uh roll call for
amendment 318 h for bill hb 306.
um
we'll begin with representative abrami
yes
representative scott wallace for pacing
mary griffin
yes
yeah him person can you say yes over
here
he's going to come he's going to come to
my uh spot here you'll see him come on
the screen you know
oh he he says he has a device okay he's
on the screen right
uh representative hollery yes
representative ober
uh i saw allegri i think we're good uh
the clerk votes yes representative
ducette yes
representative ellie okay yes
thank you representative family
representative jeanine
yes
nunes
baxter
yes
billsbury yes hooter
army
yes
ames
southworth
yes malloy yes
schomburg
representative
thank you representative tucker yes
go marlo
yes
goffman
yes gorg
yes
hacking phillips
murphy yes
and chairman major yes
chairman major the vote is 24 to nothing
for the amendment
now we
need to have a vote
a motion of octopus okay
ought to pass with the amendment
three
1 8
on house bill 306
saying none
then the
report will
as amended with amendment 3 18 8.
if you're in favor say yes
do we need an emotional conversation
let's do that
what motion about capacity
by representing right
um yeah i'll move that again
on the second that you know
representative romney
ought to pass the amendment
if you're in favor of the password of
amendment 3 18 8 you'll
respond by saying yes if you oppose
okay let's begin the roll call vote with
representative wallace yes
hillary
yes
ober
first being the clerk votes yes to set
yes
elliot
nunes yes
extra yes gillsbury yes hooter
yes army
yes ames
yes
southworth
yes gorg
yes
murphy
chairman major yes
chairman major the result of the roll
call vote was 24 to nothing in favor
the vote being 24 and nothing
hospital 3306 is amended with
amendment 3 18 8 passes by
passes and without objection we will go
pick up today
which is an act relative to sports book
locations
and we have another amendment
hey susan you're doing pretty good as a
techie
oh before we
consider the amendment
we need a motion on the floor on house
so move mr chairman representative
second
so ought to pass
otp yes
and who second that
representative wallace
wallace
okay
representative
elmir
there it is okay found it
um
i i'm presenting this amendment on
which is one that i thought
that we had agreed on
earlier on
the bill itself had two parts to it one
of them was
on the one that is here on the
screen uh
representative you want to make a motion
for us oh i want to move or to pass on
amendment 3 14 h thank you
representative how many moves ought to
pass on 3 14 eight second goodbye
tuner representative
okay
thank you
i'm good representative
yes
um
this amendment
is
on
includes the tier ii
ii wagering inside the sports book
on which
was the
primary aim of the
of the sponsor but he added into it in
case a lot of places would show up all
of a sudden that wanted to do this on
on a ban
a removal of the ban on a cap
no wait a minute let me see how i did it
a removal of the cap of 10 locations
that was in the bill that we passed last
time because
we really don't know how these things
are going to work out and some people
are worried about uh
creating
competition that on
would stop a lot of people from even
applying
for
sports locations
and as i recall representative
bromi was interested in the cap being
kept and
a number of other people spoke and
charlie uh also spoke and said that
there
he doesn't see any way that at least
within two years we're going to get even
so that another bill could be brought in
at that time when we knew more about how
these are working
so
what this amendment does is to keep
in line seven and eight the existing
language that says no more than ten
sportsbook retail locations may be in
operation at any given time
but you know it puts back the tier two
that our committee had added before it
went to
the senate
take a question
representative
i i don't have a question i just want to
speak on the amendment so just let me
know when the appropriate time is to do
representative
questions for representative eleanor
i don't see a fan but right now
he's in there
he's in the llp normal okay
representative
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you uh representative alame um i
was speaking with the sponsor about this
bill yesterday and uh i think that he
noted to me that there were 16 towns
that had applied for the licenses for
the sports betting in the state and if
we keep the cap at 10
then are we going to tell them just in
case this speeds up and if the lottery
approves more and more than they thought
they would that they are not going to be
if i presume that's to me so
on
what on we were told by the lottery was
that
it is a very complicated process to set
these up and that
they have had i think it is
eight applications to date and are only
seriously pursuing
two of them with the possibility after
that of a third
may i follow up mr chairman
would be would we consider raising that
and to me i i i believe that
on if
if they get near anywhere near the 10
that
that could then be
be considered i mean of course it could
be considered by the committee in two
years
and not next year according to our roles
unless we changed our rules
thank you representative elmi thank you
mr chair
i don't see anybody
question
okay then
speaking on the amendment
thank you mr chair i just wanted to
speak against the amendment um and i
really just think we should uh take a
step back as a committee um and and one
thing i think is important and i know we
have a wide range of ideologies and
beliefs among committee members but both
from a
um a conservative and a liberal
perspective i think um you know i think
this is a a little bit
of a rush to judgment i mean i know
there's a concern about if we go from
having a small number to 10 or more
what's the impact going to be on the
existing businesses but from a
pro-business perspective that's the
angle you want to look at this from
you have to be pro opportunity to be pro
business as greg moore from afp
testified we don't want a taxi
medallion-like system where failing
businesses that aren't actually
providing a quality service for
customers and for towns and ultimately
revenues um for the government where
they can make millions of dollars just
off the fact that they have a license
that the politicians have given them
and from a fairness perspective as well
um you know you can simply look at from
that angle um why should we make it
where if someone wants to start up
um they might have to incur a cost down
the road of millions of dollars to get
the license once we've hit that cap of
10 even if we don't think that we're
going to hit that cap necessarily that
is a potential
um
you know impact that we might be
creating without thinking we're doing so
so we should be very careful from that
and ultimately um in terms of just the
health of the the gaming system
it's not it's not kind of like the wild
west like we might originally think um
you know charlie from lottery draftkings
they're only going to approve operations
that make financial sense for everyone
involved so i think it's better to leave
it to the professionals than to have us
set this artificial cap so i'm going to
are you speaking
yes
or you have a question
well i have a question that kind of
follows on what uh representative baxter
just said
um the argument that we are creating a
new york taxi medallion
um
situation
uh
that there may be some validity to that
if you have only ten
uh books open
rather than letting the what adam smith
call the the hidden hand of the free
market guide these uh
variety of stores
um
or book locations i don't even know what
they are i don't gamble
every time i do i lose so
uh
the
it just seems to me that
maybe setting a cap on this is not
a good idea
that's my opinion on this i'm willing to
set this through
now
but i would prefer it without
a cap
we can always add one later things get
out of hand i mean that's one good one
thing government's good at is screwing
chair it's pat that's representative
representative
yeah i i did speak up early on on this
and i i did support uh
keeping the cap we gotta remember this
bill passed last year
with the cap
uh for a reason
uh
yes i'm a free market kind of guy too
but in this in this regard i i think
there's a disincentive like uh i think
representative helmy said
to businesses getting in because they
know there's only so many
people that are going to bet
uh
i i again we we voted it in this way
right now there's only two locations and
it's been over a year
uh
so i'm i'm going to uh and absolutely if
we see that we hit eight or nine
we'll have another bill we can expand it
then
uh i'm just concerned about the
disincentive of somebody because there's
a lot of money getting involved in
getting into this game
[Music]
and uh plus you have to pass the
scrutiny that the test i think is a lot
higher uh on this one in terms of
getting a a license to do this
uh
more than any other business would be uh
non-gambling business
so um i'm going to support the amendment
relax on you
okay
okay um thank you um
yeah i agree with uh much of what
representative rami just said um
and
we'll we'll vote for
the amendment with the cap in it um
and
i just have two points one is that
we worked long and hard on this
legislation i believe it was two years
ago
to get it to a point where it could get
support and be enacted
um
part of that was putting in this uh
this cap this 10
sportsbook cap and
i think that was part of the chemistry
um that led to enactment um like
you never can know for sure what
elements uh are persuasive or not but i
think that was one of them and uh
and that's not to say that it couldn't
be changed uh if uh circumstances change
and the need for
additional sports books is
apparent and on that second point um
i you may recall that i asked uh when we
heard the bill
for
information that would give us a better
understanding of sports books
you know the contracts uh that provide
for
the operation of the sports books the uh
nature of the locations the um
a number number of pieces of information
um and i'm sure we'll get that in due
course but uh there's no urgency here so
i think we should go forward with the
bill uh not change the uh
the cap and get tier two into the uh
into the system um
and uh as time goes forward uh we'll
either see increased demand for sports
book locations or we won't in the
meantime we'll get better informed on
what's what this uh concept of sports
book
translates to in in real physical and
financial forms thank you
thank you representative ames
representing southwark
uh thank you i support the amendment um
i recall the sponsors worked very hard
on this bill and i think it is too soon
to change the cap thank you
anybody else who is
testifying
or have questions
this is mr chairman
i still can't raise my hand could i
speak for a second time very briefly yes
thank you
i think
i think i think that this um is in the
nature of a bank
the people who have the sports books are
holding a great deal of money from
people and they are supposed to pay a
lot of it back
and in places where
and before they were really regulated uh
in britain they didn't do a lot of these
on
they
uh
there would be sports book
people that would just not pay it back
and on i think this is why lottery makes
it on
makes the application process very long
and
and uh
and difficult is that they have to make
sure that they are going to pay it back
chair one more follow-up question uh
representative
yeah let's not lose sight of the fact
that the major part of this bill is the
tier two betting
and that's major that will make the uh
the
ability to do the same kind of bets that
you do on the app
in person now so
i think that really accomplishes a major
move forward so
uh we should let's fight that piece and
then and then look at
eliminating the cap at another date
thank you
any further questions or comments
on the amendment representative major
this is representative berstein i'm
unable to raise my hand as well but i
would like to
um
as far as the optimal number of
locations i i have no idea perhaps the
optimal numbers too maybe it's 10 maybe
it's 20 but by limiting it
uh i don't think we serve the consumer i
mean the best way to serve the consumer
is to let the market work its course and
to let competition
uh flourish
perhaps the future is i don't know
virtual reality uh you can
as though you're in the football game in
one of the i mean who knows what the
market will come up with
but i think that limiting it and capping
it will inhibit
uh creativity and entrepreneurship and
and i think that the customer is the
loser
i'm just not smart enough to put a cap
on this thing i would much rather it be
left up to the market and and the
decision not be made centrally by a
bunch of
uh by by
by us i would rather let the market
handle it so i will be voting against
the amendment mr chair
and speak against
senator brown
listen most most of us were here when we
we voted on this bell
and we were all smarter not smart enough
to put the 10 10 cap
in then
okay anybody else wish to make comment
or
question
on the amendment
saying then then i'm going to
have
the clerk call the role if you're in
favor
of amendment
314h
you'll
respond with yes when your name is fall
if you're not in favor you will respond
by saying no
the clerk call the rules
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call on the amendment with
representative abrami yes
representative wallace yes
representative allery yes
representative ober yes
clerk votes no
representative ducette yes
okay yes
thank you sir
representative jeanine
yes representative nunes no
representative baxter
no
representative spillsbury yes
representative tutor
yes
representative olney
representative ames yes
representative southworth
yes representative malloy
yes
hamburg
representative chamber votes yes
tucker
yes
go marlo
laughman
yes gorg
yes
hacking phillips yes murphy
and chairman major yes
mr chair the vote is 21
yeses three
the vote no's 21 to 3 means it passes
now we will go to the bill
i'd be like
here's an amendment
mr chim yes
i moved to pass hb 330 as amended otp
world amendment three ota sorry
h
okay representative schamberg's second
said
who moved it
representative dussette moved it was
ought to possibly amended
further discussion on the
bill
as amended
any further discussion on the bill as
amended
seeing then i'm going to ask the clerk
call the rules if you're in favor of the
bill to pass as amended
respond by saying yes if you oppose
respond by saying no
could you take down the amendment
yes
are we ready for the roll call mr chair
let's begin the roll call with
representative abrami the
representative wallace yes
owerry yes
ober
yes
the clerk votes yes
elliott
yes
thank you
nunes
yes
baxter
pillsbury yes
tudor
yes army
yes
ames yes
southward
yes malloy yes
jamberg representative schamberg votes
yes
tucker
yes so marlo
yes
one more time tom
gorg
yes
[Music]
murphy
yes
chairman major yes
chairman major the vote was 24 yes's
zero knows
the vote being 24-0
the motion
on
about to pass
and said
okay
without objection to go on consent do we
i don't see any objections so we're
can i ask a question yeah of uh alan who
who made the motion on 306 was that
value
no
yes
seconded by abram
yeah almi
uh
moved it and abrami seconded it for the
amendment and the motion of 306. thank
you
uh representative burstein i
i i want to double you just said
just to double check that um on
the amendment
318h
is that and that was
motion
representative almighty second
representative abrami
that is correct okay and and then on the
uh 306 uh
octopass 306 as amended
uh could you tell me again who
ami made the
motion and
representative brahmy second
that is correct thank you
representative bursting
yes
um what was the
vote on the amendment 314 that we just
did please
the vote was 21-3
in favor
and one other thing about your not being
able to raise your hand
yes
yes did you try signing out and then
signing back in at lunchtime or over
lunch time
we're representatives to take the lunch
break but before we do that
just
just mute your uh
video and your audio
representative major yes
um i have copied and i'm sending you the
nhpr article where it does quote you
oh thank you
it again it's very positive it's about
you supporting mary and the committee
being very professional so it's a nice
article for that section oh thank you i
hadn't realized
you can add that to your memoirs
thank you tom
any questions before we break up
the governor's on providing giving his
budget now so
we'll see you back at one o'clock
thank you
and just
oh
so
okay
i've got two minutes after one
okay good let's start our camera to stop
i'm getting see a few more faces here
wait one more minute and then we can
you're muted
sorry
it's been going the whole time i didn't
think to stop it
i don't know what it has
well i don't think anything nobody was
on it was email but we'll look at it
okay
i did
listen to the bulk of the budget address
it was over in half hour
yeah
meals and rooms tax reduction of the
business enterprise tax and reduction
i just remembered i didn't uh have
somebody to look in on my dog had to
scramble to get somebody to go over the
house i can't believe i forgot to call
the kids this morning they went up so
um can i make a request of our attendees
we have 15
uh sign ups to speak
and
if they could raise their hand
um when we want them
when you call them it will help me find
them much quicker all right rolling
through 45's 46 names now
on my list i've got about 20 people to
signed up
to speak
and there's about 180 people that
signed up
the first building
jenny you should be aware that charlie
yes i see him
mr chairman
yes what's the first bill
the first bill is a dueser house bill
okay
i shouldn't have said dozers it's a
hammering bill
i want to be one step ahead of you
i don't see charlie in the list
no he's on the list but he's on on the
screen already
well there it is okay jen must have let
him in okay yes
sorry
are we all set jenny
i'm all set thank you
okay
we need to open the public hearing on
house bill
626-500
and act relative to historic horse
racing
the prime sponsor is representative
romney
and representative browning want to
introduce your bill
thank you mr chairman uh for the record
state representative romney rocking camp
19 town of stratham
later introduced house bill 626
so you're aware there's also a similar
bill over in the senate uh senate bill
with many of the senators uh sponsoring
that bill
last time we had a similar bill
uh that got very positive vote out of
weights and means it wasn't unanimous
but we got a very positive vote out of
ways he means
that bill was tabled on the floor at 3
a.m in the morning
in the session that lasted until 4 a.m
and if you recall
the next day is when the state house
closed down
for 3-4 months
our plan was to pull that bill off the
table uh but that never that opportunity
never occurred
so with that we refiled the bill
uh
let me explain what historic racing is
first off historic racing is a new game
that would be brought into our venues
that support charitable gaming
so this these machines can only
be located in charitable gaining
locations
let me start with the
kind of the history of perry mutual
wagering in new hampshire
perry mutual wagering goes back to the
1930s
became the basis for our horse and dog
track bedding
over the years four major locations spun
up
and lasted many many years
but i would say died at their own weight
or of uh changing generations uh the
racing was too slow for the
new younger people
uh too much time between races things
like that
and then the horse race on the on the
dog track side there was a lot of bad
press also about
the way dogs were being treated
therefore
live racing disappeared over the last
decade or so
the current statute says some chaos
racing can occur at any former track as
i said there was four of them
that for many years was rockingham park
and seabrook dog track
until rockingham was torn down several
years ago to make way for a mixed-use uh
uh development
so that leaves
seabrook which is now called the brook
is the only location with simulcast
racing and when i say simulcast racing
that means you can place a bet anywhere
in the country on any race that's going
on
live
the reason i mention all this is the
point here is that the systems and
controls are in place already to support
historic racing
all of this is based on the same
technology
and we already have a regulatory
structure in place
for parry mutual racing
so let's let me spend a minute now
talking about
i know the members who've been around a
while know what this is about but for
the new members
so what is historic racing
so tarot gaming race uh locations will
get terminals
that which bets can be placed on horse
races that occurred in the past
the terminals are connected to a
again that have occurred already
the turtle makes available true and
actual
past performance information to aid
players in making informed choices as to
how to bet
so what am i what am i talking about so
if you're on a track you have the racing
form the racing forum tells you
everything you want to know about the
horses that are racing the jockeys etc
these machines have drop down screens to
tell you the same information but it
doesn't tell you the name of the horse
it gives you a b c d
and horse a
this is its record etc etc does the same
for the jockeys doesn't tell you the
name of the jockeys so you can't
identify
any of these it doesn't tell you the
location of the race either so you can't
ever go back and
and
try to figure out you know what race
this was and know the actual outcome
before you place it back that's the
point
but you place the bet as if you're at
the racetrack
again this is paramutual wagering
so winnings are based on all others
there is something called a totalizer
that calculates trend nuclear pools and
payouts associated with each winning
wager
again i'm going to emphasize that we the
lottery commission is very familiar with
totalizers because of seabrook and
because of the
channel cast we deal with totalizers
that are
where this data goes and it
calculates the winnings
so
these machines will be collected to the
totalizer that will calculate the
winnings
just as and again i'm emphasizing this
because lottery is very familiar with
this it isn't something new that they
have to learn
there is a quick pick feature that
allows betting on on favorites
so
we when you're if you're i i think i've
been to a heart track twice in my life
but there's a big board before the race
you see what the odds are the odds are
changing constantly until until uh the
race begins
and many people will wait and place
their bed until the very end
and they will place it
uh you know parts one is two to one
three two is five to one then one they
want to see what the odds are
right before and that's based on the
people betting
so
uh
there's a feature in here part of the
quick
quick pick feature is that
my understanding is that it
automatically sends you to
that uh information so that you you if
you want to bet that way in a quick way
you will know that and you can bet that
way
so why do i support historic racing
very simple
and this all of us have to have a little
soul-searching on this bill
i i support this wholeheartedly because
it expands the offerings of charitable
gaming
and you understand that we support 500
charities throughout new hampshire right
now
and i'm going to talk about in a minute
is that this bill will expand the number
of charities that can become involved
which is a different this is different
you must have a charitable gaming
license to offer the game
and again there are 15 locations in the
state that offer charitable gaming
the latest one up in conway area
so what's new about this bill is that it
requires a licensee to contract with two
charities
each
for the licensed game days we heard uh
we heard uh president gore mentioned
earlier that you know you had 10 dates
so your charity you get 10 dates
assigned to you
so what this bill is going to do is say
well we're going to have two charities
just for these any winnings on these
machines to go to charities
there will be two charities to sign
uh the ability
those those dates for any winnings from
those machines and that they would be
split 50 50 between the charities uh for
those 10 days
so this is something new
and again this is the other the other
piece in there and just something we can
debate
uh
the charities within the executive
council district on the facility
location will have will be given
preference
uh this goes back to some of the earlier
conversation about who gets who gets
choice who gets picked who doesn't get
picked
uh there's some guidance here that says
for these machines that within a within
a executive council district
that
they would get preference over other
charities
again the point is that we have a very
long list of charities that want to get
involved with this
and if you've seen from all the mail
you've been getting
obviously the terrible locations really
do appreciate that we have this form of
operation to help their charities out
and of course the only reason i i
support this let's not forget the
chairman of gaming also supports
education
the majority of what the state gets
winds up going into the uh the education
trust fund
so let's do the math this is the for
this is
it takes you a while when you read it to
figure it out i i had a call
charlie mcintyre back twice to say do i
have this right
the licensee commission meaning the
owner of the charitable location
on all historic race parry mutual pools
shall be at a rate
not greater than 12 percent
so that means the the organizations that
run it will well off the top take 12
percent
uh but
it's in statutes not to exceed 12
it could be anywhere 12 or less
when i talked to
charlie mcintyre he said the odds are
it's going to be set around 10 percent
by but the individual location sets
their own level
uh more than likely it's going to be 10
uh so probably anywhere between 10 and
12. but for sake of argument let's just
say it's 12 at 12 it can't be any higher
than that
so that means 88
would go back of the winnings would go
back to the players
so how much did the charities in the
state get
so of the 12
25 percent of that goes to the charities
and to the state
so that's a pot
so
of that
[Music]
these
the charities get 35
and the state gets 65 of the 25 percent
so when we have more sessions we can we
can talk this one to death but uh i can
explain it
when we're doing work sessions a little
more if there's confusion on that one
but again that means that
the education trust fund gets a good
then there's two other money things
if you go to section 5 of the bill roman
five
i'm going to read this
uh 100 of the of the odd sense of all
redistribution based on each dollar
wager exceeding the sum equal to the
next lowest multiple of 10 known as
breakage like i could just said breakage
and we can have a conversation about
what breakage is
shall be paid to the lottery commission
and used as payment for problem
gaming gaming so that's where
the money's going to come from to uh
into the into the problem gaming fun
then also there's another section five
roman five of the bell
section nine
i was gonna excuse me section nine of
the bill
talks about unclaimed tickets to go to
special fund rsa 284 coleman 21j
but i understand what that is
all of lottery and charitable gaming
uh
revenues go into this fund
what happens is
at some point in time
that money is trans anything that's
expenses for running the lottery come
out of that okay so after the expenses
come out of that fund
the rest of it goes to the education
trust fund so basically it's saying it's
pointed there
the lottery
takes out its expense and then the rest
goes
to the education trends fund and that's
the number when we do our estimates
that's the number that we we see that
okay
hopefully everyone got this that there
was a fiscal note uh
i asked uh i didn't see mine being sent
to me directly so i asked web center
major to forward it to everybody this
morning hopefully you got it
so lottery is these the fiscal note came
from lottery itself
they estimate between 5.7 and 5.8
million will go to the charities
a little over 12 million will go to the
uh to lottery
which means majority of that is is is
going to the education trust fund
uh by the way that number includes the
unclaimed tickets that i had mentioned
before
and then they estimated another 820
000 goes to the probably problem gaming
gaming uh activities uh than that from
so these are pretty big numbers
uh and this is why i support this bill
i think we really really need to
uh
think about how we're going to support
our charities more
uh just something uniquely in new
hampshire and i'm going to get to that
in a minute
the one thing i forgot to mention is
that i mentioned that you need a
operator's license under rsa287-d
a game operator
meaning you have to own all these
facilities
but for if you're going to install these
machines in your facility you also need
a peri mutual wagering license under rsa
and the reason we put that in there
is that the background checks
are even more stringent than to get a
license to be a terrible
location so it's it's it's the same
same background check that you get as if
you were you're running a racetrack
so i don't want to i wanted to emphasize
that
now i'm going to go through some of the
other sections very quickly i'll mention
them to you
if you go to section two of the bill
insurance historic racing machines are
programmed and operated
for perimeter wagering only
a lot of machines are based on random
number generator these machines are not
based on that they are based on pairing
mutual racing of rebellion totally
different
and when i say that they're playing
against others betting and not betting
on the house when you're when you're
betting on regular gambling you're
defending against the house with these
machines you're betting against others
that are playing very important piece to
remember
section 5 roman 2
limits applicants for
license
for these machines to to those who
uh who have game operational or greater
licenses to conduct terrible gaming as
of may first 2020.
i want to talk about that and also let's
look at section 10 and 11 at the same
time
open up historic racing to others
on july 1st 2024
i'm going to read why
this is in the meantime i want to say
this in the meantime it doesn't stop
anyone who qualifies
to gain a
a game operator license to open up a new
charitable gaming facility
but they must wait until july 1st 2024
to also have a historic racing license
the reason we did that
is that we wanted to make sure
that
we
we're gonna have facilities opening just
to have these machines
we wanted to we wanted to make sure that
that that didn't happen and that that
was the logic so we were delaying a
couple years
uh to allow
any other facilities to use these
machines other than the 15 that that
exist or anybody who decides to get
licensed before may 1st uh well
we're in 2021 anybody who's licensed as
of may 1st 2020.
uh uh section five roman three
individual wages are capped at twenty
five dollars
also in that section each licensee to
have a responsible gaming plan
uh that was also part of the uh problem
gaming discussion we had last term that
we wanted to make sure that these
facilities have a responsible gaming
plan that they can enact if they feel
someone is abusing their what they're
doing with gambling
uh section 5 roman 4
employees or owners of companies
that are involved with the hardware
software not be allowed to play in new
hampshire and i think that's
self-explanatory
uh section five roman
uh
six
uh rule making authority of the lottery
okay that's self-explanatory section
five
7 historic racing machines can only be
utilized when other charitable gaming
games are being offered
and i think uh what we did there is we
didn't want to make sure that if channel
gaming
facility closed
their you know game other games of
chance
uh at nine o'clock
that they weren't allowed to stay open
till midnight or using these machines
only
all right so those are some of the major
components of the of the bill
i'm sure we're going to have a a work
session or two on this on this
let me tell you what the argument's
going to be
you've been there before
uh you know we can hear historic racing
machines and slot machines
and my argument's going to be
not true
you're never going to find a casino that
has these machines because they're too
slow
we're going to hear probably someone's
gonna talk about the recent kentucky
ruling
uh and let's see kentucky's not even
donate but that's not true
uh my understanding about that that
that ruling was it was a turf battle
between agencies in kentucky
and that if if you look right now
kentucky still is using these these
historic racing machines
i'm sure we're going to have some
discussion about the quick play feature
of the machine
um
i'm going to i don't want to do it today
but uh when we're in our work session we
could talk about
uh that there's expanding support out
there for charitable gaming
uh
in recent polls
we're probably gonna debate about
uh the delay
of not allowing new machine machines in
i'm willing to listen to those debates
uh we may even have a debate on the pet
limit um
and the other question is really is this
a viable way to support our charities in
what's going to back up two more
years about 20 minutes you have much
more to go well given i i yeah i got two
more comments
two more comments okay
uh
well it's a complicated bill i mean it
isn't like some of these other bills
there were two lions so
uh
big big picture
large destination casinos are never
gonna happen
in new hampshire
it had a chance ten years ago
with the closing of rockingham park
which was the only logical place to have
a a
destination casino
we're not going to find chair
any kind of casino pass in this state is
my
that's my humble opinion
so now is the time to let's support the
model that we have
that supports charities and education
this is a model unique to new hampshire
if we had large-scale
uh casinos coming here
a lot of those monies would leave our
state and go to
and go to
nevada go to vegas by the big companies
that used to bid on these things
so
let's support what we have i i agree
with our discussion earlier that we
should we should tighten up our
regulations absolutely
and one final thing uh we're going to
have the discussion i'm sure on
committee
and this is something that the
commission is also going to be looking
at that we're probably going to be
also in the packet i i sent to everybody
was a pie chart
and this is the breakout of a hundred
thousand dollars bet
uh ninety two dollars goes back to the
player two dollars and fifty cents uh
the cost of the machines and all the
hookups with the total later riser and
all that
two to two dollars and forty cents city
uh for operating expenses to having the
building the electricity whatever
two dollars goes to the charity of the
state and the dollar ten goes to the
operator share
meaning the owners of the facility
uh as profit but remembering that
some of that goes back into capital
improvements that they reinvest in their
facilities
so with that i uh
i'm looking forward to our discussion in
ways and means
and i'm going to take any questions you
have
thank you for your testimony
representative romney questions from the
committee
you mentioned the
operator share
oh for somebody on the line that could
help us with this
can you give us a definition of our
example capital improvement costs
[Music]
what i'm saying that that is the profit
to the order that to the to the uh
facility
organizations that are on these
locations
but what they what they do is they they
put that money in their pocket
or they
they take some of that money and
reinvest it in
you know uh better ambiance better
equipment better whatever
so that that's what that means follow up
mr chairman follow up
uh then
you talk about them putting the money in
their pocket what percentage the
operator's share of a dollar ten goes
into a separate account
for capital cost
capital improvement cost so that salary
wages
etc uh
are not being co-mingled
is there a separate account
no there is there isn't a second account
no it's going into the pocket and that's
it
but that's but that's the that's what's
left it that that's the amount that's
left by after subtracting out all the
other costs that is what's left
uh and out of that if if they wanted to
enhance their facility
where does that money come from
and it comes out of the owner's
pocket i'm saying that that's that's the
piece that
instead of putting it in their pocket
it would go to
uh
they would bear the expense of
uh enhancing the facility or making it
better
thank you mr chairman um representative
abram can you at the very end of your
testimony you gave the breakdown
i think of where each dollar went out of
a hundred can you can you repeat that
oh okay i had i mailed out a packet to
everybody but i'll do it
ready so 100 bet
92 dollars goes back to the players
2.50
uh the cost of the machines
2.40
operator expenses that's heat light
you know all electricity
uh
two dollars goes to the charity in the
state
and the dollar ten goes to the
operator's share
uh
which also is part of their capital
improvement plan
if they have one
and i got these estimates from
the uh
they took a survey of all of the
existing locations
and that's where we got these numbers
from these are the numbers that they
shared
with us
and again
this is something that
you know i don't think this
committee can handle is between now and
the time we have to vote this bill but
uh when we have the
if we pass the bill on the uh
the commission
i i think this is something that uh
representative ames is looking to take a
look at as well
okay uh
representing
thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you representative abrami for all
your diligent work hard work on this um
you you talked about a few things and
i'm going to keep this very brief
because i know we have a lot of people
that want to uh
submit testimony but you talked a bit
about what some of the opponents will be
bringing up when we hear these these
arguments
to pass this legislation you spoke
specifically about the argument that
these are slot machines
would you agree that
the opponents to this legislation have
made that argument
and
would you also agree or would you
disagree with the fact that uh hhr uh
historic horse racing is completely
different from any kind of uh existing
electronic games they
they're going to make that argument that
this is a different component we already
have
electronic games in the state visa the
lucky 7 machines kino now the sports
betting kiosks
the way it was described in the way it
could be best described is that this is
another component for the charities to
benefit from as a matter of fact in your
piece of legislation you built in a
component that adds charities to this
the the one argument and and we can get
into the specifics of of these
definitively not being slot machines
because they are in fact not slot
machines and we and we heard that
testimony from charlie mcintyre last
biennium along with others
um
the one thing he didn't miss is the
argument that seems to keep arising here
in relation to gaming addiction
um
and and these are unfounded
unsubstantiated
yet uh
perpetual attempts
to uh
to derail
this uh simple addition to a charitable
gaming base the revenues that these
charities get and more importantly that
the end recipients from these charities
get
um
is there a question of this excuse me uh
mr chairman chairman of this committee
excuse me i am asking a question
these unfounded allegations of addiction
perpetuate and continue to perpetuate
submitting these to charities and others
as we work towards us would you believe
that representative
yeah i would believe that
let's let's face it if you go around
new england
uh
all those states with the exception of
vermont
has
has some kind of gaming
vermonters lottery i imagine but
all the other states have have true
casinos
with real slot machines
these aren't real slot machines they
aren't slot machines
they may look like them a little bit but
they're not
the betting is the mutual it's not based
on a random number generator and the
player actually has the ability to
change the outcome of his bet you you if
you pay attention to the form that you
have
you're making an intelligent bet
not based on some random number
generator whether you're lucky or not
so
yeah i i
you know
we were the first state in the nation to
have lottery
uh
so i i think it and in this bill we have
plenty of spots where we include money
to go to problem gambling and to have
also to have the
uh
the uh the plan
if
in place if uh the facility sees
somebody who is uh abusing
uh
representative
thank you mr chairman um thank you
representative abrami for taking my
question i to agree uh you've done a lot
of work on this and i have the
packet in front of me i'm looking at
your pie chart
where 100
of wages goes and i just want to take
one tiny little section of that the very
first
uh piece that says two dollars
and it says it looks like charity slash
state does that mean that that two
dollars is split between of the day the
charity and the state so that's a that's
uh what split
35 goes to the charity
65 goes to the state okay
follow-up question
yes
of of the charity that you say 35 cent
goes to charity so that 35 is then split
between the two charities of the day
um
yes
[Music]
represented elliott
thank you mr chairman
um in the old days
uh the charities
were
chosen by the general manager at the
racetrack in salem new hampshire
the way i understand this bill now
this is a
totally different situation
where the
lottery commission is the one that
chooses
the various charities that we're going
to be receiving funds
okay i i rely on
charlie mcintyre for this he's on the
line he'll
when we get to charlie
ask that question please
right we'll have chad take care of that
he'll explain
it be helpful to him explain how it
works now
in terms of who gets who gets the slot
and who doesn't and what we're going to
do with this new bill is to i think
there's going to be some rule making
involved in this as well
uh so
let's hold that off to
uh
charlie mcintyre thank you
representative
and represent a lot
may i interject for a moment there's
some background noise in the lob
i don't know if some some microphones
might help
yeah
they looked at each other and that they
yes
thank you mr chairman
i want to point out uh one thing you
know we heard that uh these are not slot
machines because you won't see historic
horse racing
machines in casinos
i'd like to point out that casinos don't
have these machines because they do have
slot machines
and this may actually further
demonstrate that these historic horse
racing machines which kentucky ruling
says are slot machines are used where
slot machines are not explicitly allowed
so if you can't have one you have the
other they are competing in the same
gaming space
i think that further demonstrates a
point now that's not to say for or
that
i think if we're having an honest
conversation we say these these behave
an awful lot when they're used as the
autoplay feature and the quick pick they
have an awful lot
like a slot machine
and uh
that's why we should treat it uh
accordingly and with the same level of
concern that we have for slot machines
because we don't allow those in the
state
thank you
i was fine thank you representative
i'm going to respond
so i've asked i have asked charlie
mcintyre to explain the kentucky ruling
his view he's and he's a lawyer and he's
probably most knowledgeable of all and
on these things so
he's going to i'm asking specifically to
address the kentucky ruling
when i bring him up
ask him that question i've got a few
people to roll before that
uh representation jeans
do you have another question
your hand is up i'm sorry mr chairman i
didn't take my hand down
okay anybody else
sorry
yes
okay
and we'll go to the
next presenter and that is
representative
i'm sorry but i've never had somebody
talk about most of the things he thinks
that are going to be said in opposition
to this bill before
the testimony was finished
um
yes
i want to start by on giving people the
history of
on at least recent in the last 50 years
of
gambling in this state
maybe it's 40 years
on we had something called tr trap monte
carlo nights
on they were
charitable gaming uh they were traveling
circuses they went
on at least for the smaller towns like
mine mine was a town back then
and
they they would come one night or two
nights during the year
usually
every six months in my town and they
would rent a hall and
they would set up all of the machines
that
you see in normal charitable gaming now
on and people would come and play
uh i i think it was a single charity in
the town would get part of the proceeds
and the local police had the oversight i
think there must have been uh a
select board approval
when they came
on
charitable gaming
came in because of two tiny bills that
were put in
in edna when suddenly all of the
gambling bills were sent over there
maybe 10 12 years ago
on and
that
removed the monte carlo nights and
replaced it with
the ability for
operators to set up large sites around
the state most of them ended up in the
south of the state where the population
is
owned by private individuals who were
doling out nights to charities as people
mentioned according to
providing
friendly natives i think
uh
around them
and uh
but they could solicit and they did
uh at least early on i don't know now uh
they they would solicit charities from
all over the state they had the power to
do that
it was
on gradually as they did this they
incorporated and
killed
the bingo industry
uh within within them i don't know if
there's any bingo halls just bingo left
on
and
the
and on and
under these bills the charities
eventually got 35
i believe neil kirk insisted on that
uh and of the profit and the state got
less cost than
less
a lesser amount than it cost to regulate
the industry
the host towns had no say in whether
these were set up or not
because it was
sociable games it was poker
uh some roulette not much some craps not
much uh
and um
and the bingo
section
and i think i'm leaving one out but
uh
so then we came along and we put in keno
and sports betting but we put them in
the nearly extinct racing statutes
uh
under direct state control by lottery
with the towns able to opt in and then
opt out again
if they wanted to
uh
this because these games mostly involve
less social interaction
and more chances of creating
meanwhile we were considering casino
bills every term
and um
i'd like to point out that uh one of the
things we found was that about 70 of the
profit of any casino was slot machines
um
and probably still is
and in the largest task force that i
think has ever been assembled of state
legislators
um
equally divided among pros and cons i
think in the end we had
uh
one
there were something like
50 people there and it came down to to
one more vote in favor of killing the
one of our disc decisions was to avoid
spreading little slots parlors all over
the state because they would be really
hard to regulate
they would raise little money compared
to
a big casino
and for
those of us on the
anti-side
on it would cost dearly in economic
losses and social damage due to the
increase in addiction from the proximity
effect
on
i wanted
sorry i'm having
trouble reading the notes i rewrote
during lunch
um
okay i'll i'll forget that little piece
uh so now you're proposing to solve this
problem
of not enough money for regulation that
we have with the finance committee
on
by putting the most addictive form in
in-person gambling
slot machines into the little regulated
uh charity gaming framework
and
no
no way to say anything because
charitable gaming is social
and
doesn't addict much
yes you say it can be played as a very
slow horse racing machine
that is frustrating to the operator
because
he loses money
he has to have a lot of bets in order to
get his money
on he doesn't
gain
by winning the bet but he gains by
having people playing again and again
and the customers find it frustrating
because they can't make their selections
fast enough to set the bet and end up
having the machine set it for them when
the machine sets it for them the machine
uses that there are pyramid
mutual statistics involved but they use
random generator statistics to pick the
races
on that that the people are going to
watch
and and i believe that they
base whether they win or not on the odds
that were current at the time that the
game started the race started the
original race started
so it's a mixture
and that may be why uh
kentucky i haven't looked into the
kentucky decision but i i did just send
everybody a video guide which includes a
newscast which i thought was reporting
pretty
neutrally on
from people who were reacting to the
kentucky decision
um
so
what happens is that almost everybody
that's playing these machines sits down
at the machine and hits what is usually
called autocad
that button and that button
turns it into a somewhat slow slot
machine
so it isn't
competitive with
the full slot machines that are in
massachusetts or maine
but it is on only slightly slow
slower
two two seconds instead of a half second
or something like that
and
and so they play that slot machine until
they can
they are sensible and withdraw
or they lose all the money they brought
and if they could use a credit card they
may just keep going
so what is this
because we put
on
sports betting into racing
we are putting
this one under charitable gaming which
means that towns have never been able to
vote and will never be able to vote
on
and i would just like to end by saying
that i come from one of the
16 towns
on
in which a
a gentleman moved in and put in a poker
palace
about six months i think before the
first bill surfaced
and uh
he's had a
poker games going there i'm
not sure whether it was through covet or
not but he's still there and there's he
still writes this sign on the outside
that says casino and i every now and
then get a constituent going what
is in our town
and i explained to them that they're all
calling them casinos now
on
it it has
for a long time i'm not sure whether it
is still on lebanon has been changing it
has been opposed to this kind of thing
it is going to be required to accept it
and the the place that he picked to put
it is in the middle of a large number
of pretty much all of our subsidized
housing for
the
low-income elders
for the disabled and for on recovering
alcoholics
so um
newly uh newly housed homeless people
forgot that one
um
so
these these are
the groups that cannot do not have a lot
to do with their time and are lonely are
the ones most susceptible to slot
machines and most needing watching and
they're not going to get watching under
this bill as far as i can tell
there are any questions for
representative
representatives
thank you mr chairman representative
almighty without going deep uh but just
bringing out a couple issues here
we we talked about um earlier today and
it's been mentioned again and you
mentioned uh enforcement and oversight
and if i recall correctly uh
charlie mcintyre last
uh biennium
talked
to the point where
machine gaming and i i think he he
mentioned the lucky seven machines the
kino machines
and the like he would rather
be in charge of those because
he did it easier for him to regulate the
easier they're harder to manipulate as
opposed to a uh a blackjack dealer or a
polka dealer or anything so i i would uh
i would submit that this uh at least
charlie mcintyre from lottery's
uh statements last year would would help
us in that enforcement and oversight
and also you made a statement and i
still contend as do many people who
understand these machines that these are
not slots but you mentioned that
these machines have a random generator
of some sort and uh you spoke to it
specifically
uh as far as the races what it is is
there is the way it was explained to all
of us as a committee there's a pool of
races whether that be 200 000 300 000
races and yes they are randomly
generated
so those
patrons can choose the odds and choose
the race as to how they want it to
finish there is in no way shape or form
a random number generator involved with
the historic horse racing machine so so
can you explain where you got that from
representatives
hold on
representative said
is that a form of a question that's what
i ask that i want to know where she's
getting uh that there's random numbered
generators in historic racing machines
okay
on yes there are in historic racing
machines something has to choose the
races that come up at any given time
and it is done randomly
i explained and i am talking now about
autocad
when you press the button and you turn
it into a semi-slot machine
on
then
on the machine picks the race and it did
before too
but the machine on is the one that
that
produces the odds that you're going to
use and the odds that you're going to
use as i recall with this
is the on paramutual odds that were in a
place at the time
that
on
for the the three
winning horses
uh no
uh
the machine i think the the machine uses
paramutual
odds someone else can explain this on to
determine
on how you're going to bet on that but
you aren't determining it you are
telling the machine to determine it
and at that
but at the original point
where
which race you're getting is
is a random numbers generator
follow up mr chair
it may be also in the other
well what you're describing is a set
set of odds in a race that was uh
may have taken place 20 30 years ago
there was a big difference from a random
number generator
and a historic race there is no
uh random member gen generation in any
of these
machines or they would be slot machines
and they are not
miss representative
what i said
was that there is in picking which race
comes up
when you start playing
that is not the odds themselves but
i believe that there must be some kind
of random generator inside
because otherwise on
when you are in autocad i am not in the
horse racing parts of this the horse
racing part of this
on
is
cancelled by most people when they
get on the machine they hit autocad
on
and under that something has to decide
what the odds are the person who hit it
hasn't done that they just keep hitting
the button
okay i think the point has been made on
who can explain the inside of these
machines
but there has to be
random in there or else you are cheating
the customer
is there any more questions for
representation
so
could i just
add the part that i'd forgotten on we
about eight six eight years ago we put
into the law because people kept on
saying oh no it's not a slot machine we
put into the law that
both slot machines and historic horsing
racing machines were banned this bill
takes out the latter
where was that
it's early in the bill i think
but we brought that up last time and um
and it got into this bill the next time
i mean
um
it's in on
the section starting at line seven on
page
deleting on line
and then adding historic in in several
[Music]
romans 7 was written for you
representative army according to
this no it's not romans 7 it's roman
roman 6
which is is
on altering the existing law
in the places i said
it's lines
[Music]
that's going to have to be evaluated
any further questions for representative
elevator
person is neil kirk
yes i will
can you hear me mr chairman yes i can
hear you i haven't heard you for a long
time
thank you very much mr chairman members
of the committee for the record i'm neil
kirk i live in ware
and i'm representing myself
um
i have nine points about this bill which
i hope the committee will
despite the arguments of the proponents
um house bill 626 cheats the charities
i didn't have access to this year's
fiscal note because it came out so
recently i just heard about it now
but last year's is pretty similar on uh
house bill 1646
in round numbers
historic racing
this year
uh would produce about six million
dollars for the charities
12 million dollars for the state and 50
million dollars for the operators that's
on a gross bet of about 55
550 million dollars with 12
of the gross profits divided in the way
that i said
in percentages the charities are getting
nine percent the state's getting 16
and the operators are getting 75 percent
i i don't understand with those
percentages how this bill can be said to
be
of benefit to charitable gaming when
both the state and the operators get so
much more than the charities do indeed
in some of the video slot machines bills
that we've had in the past the charities
were getting 18
the state was getting 50
and the operators were only getting 32
in other words the charities were
getting twice as much
as they are now the state was getting
three times as much
and the operators were getting
somewhat less than half as much so if
argued as a bill to favor charitable
gaming i think the proportions of money
going to charity is much much too low
point number two
i don't understand why there's no local
control um in this bill we've always
done that for
lotteries uh video slots and others and
keno and
horse and sports betting we always had a
local control element but not here
i don't understand why that's the case
and i hope the committee will look into
that
for many if not most players this is
number three
historic racing machines act as video
slot machines technically they're not
but as a practical matter for players
they are they're a bit slower
than video slot machines but most
players are going to have the machine
pick
their horses for them and you will
simply approve the machine's picks takes
maybe two seconds
um but as a practical matter it acts in
terms of the speed the excitement and
everything that people want from from
gaming it acts just like video slot
machines
if that's not the case here then i think
you need to eliminate the machine picks
and just make it into a true power
mutual game where the player has to bet
the odds
and and make the bets then it would be
different from slot machines
there's no there's no limit on the
number of slot machines
the number of excuse me historic racing
machines
in effect we're creating 16 mini casinos
we've never done that
i think you need to consider whether or
not there should be a limit on the
number of these machines
fifth
this bill is classic
crony capitalism
the bill creates a three-year monopoly
contrary to the words and spirit of the
state constitution and the nature of a
free enterprise economic system
part second article 83 says quote
fair and free competition in the trades
and industries is an inherent and
essential right of the people and should
be protected against all monopolies and
conspiracies which tend to hinder or
destroy it
unquote
as you know
um
section 284 22b 2 which is page 2 line
grants a monopoly to a small number of
people game operators licensed as of may
1st 2020 for three years
until july first twenty twenty four
this is special interest legislation
how much money will these folks make
that the rest of us can because the
legislature
gives them a special privilege a
monopoly that our state constitution
warns against
number six
this bill allows people as young as 18
to use these machines where in all of
the casino bills that we've seen it's
been 21 years
mass maine connecticut 21 years why is
it that we're allowing younger people to
use these machines
number seven
this bill is going to take 550 million
dollars out of the local economy
and put it into these many casinos
this is a significant economic impact on
local businesses including restaurants
and theaters
the committee needs to look carefully as
to whether or not this is a desirable
way
uh to have our state's gross domestic
product reallocated
number eight
there is inadequate regulation of these
machines in new hampshire we've got
three investigators for 12 facilities
versus rhode island which has 32
regulators for one facility
previous casino bills have had pages of
statutory regulation regulators and
financing
i doubt the lottery commission can
adequately supervise 550 million dollars
of cash going through these sites
the bill practically invites fraud the
way it's set up to the detriment of
charities among others
and in new hampshire no less
nine and finally
this bill would allow people to use i
believe credit cards unless there's some
other way and some other part of the
statute that prohibits this
i believe that this should be a
cash-only venture to protect people from
getting so involved that they
overuse the credit that may be available
to them this is an important issue for
the important issue for those people who
are concerned about problem gaming
the bill needs substantial work to deal
with these issues mr chairman and if the
committee has the time and interest in
doing so
it should retain the bill or if possible
fix it while in committee if not
if you don't have the time and you don't
believe you can retain the bill then
vote the bill itl and have the sponsors
revise the bill and submit it again next
session
that concludes my testimony mr chairman
i'd be pleased to answer any questions
thank you mr clerk for your testimony
questions
so no questions from the committee we
thank you for your testimony thank you
okay uh
i'm going to do is i'm going to call
charlie mcintyre up
most of these questions are fresh
charlie
mcintyre
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee this is charlie mcintyre
from the lottery uh and with me
is our chief compliance officer john
conforty
i have no prepared testimony on mr
chairman uh certainly
i know a lot of questions i'm happy to
answer them here and certainly make
myself as well as any staff members
that you would need available for any
work sessions
in case you want to get to other
witnesses
during public hearing
you have to unmute yourself
representative elliott i get it okay
uh thank you
um the old days the the general manager
of the racetrack determined which uh
people were gonna be involved in the
charitable gambling proceeds
so
my question to mr mcintyre is
uh is this the
now this authority now being uh taken
over by the lottery commission
does do you
or your organizations are you the one
that chooses which charities are going
to participate
uh think of the question representative
the uh the answer is no um we audit the
charitable activity uh review it
investigate it but we don't choose the
senator
thank you mr chairman just
in in brief uh
charlie a lot of a lot of people
mentioned the the quote unquote kentucky
decision today could you give us a
little
a brief on on what you may or may not
know about this
certainly uh i've reviewed it obviously
i went to law school our chief
compliance officer has reviewed the case
uh we stole him from the attorney
general's office where he was a senior
assistant a.g
i think
we have three attorneys actually in the
building probably more than anybody but
the ag's office
um it relates specifically to an
application of the power mutual law of
kentucky it doesn't opine as to what a
machine is or is not it just says it
doesn't it didn't fully comport with
their pair of mutual laws and john if
you want to add something to it
yeah that's correct i mean this is
relating very specifically to what the
kentucky
what the kentucky definition of
paramutual wagering is and how the pools
are generated and replenished um so it
was a very specific application
relating to
um power mutual wagering under kentucky
law uh not
very much applicable to
the definition of the type of machine
that that that
an hhr machine would be whether it would
fit
would you identify who it is that just
spoke i'm sorry um mr chairman that was
john conforty who was our chief
compliance officer
okay he previously was with the attorney
general's office in his prior life so
he's a lawyer um just like me
just better hook follow-up mr chair
follow-up representative
uh just
real quick um i wonder
a are these machines still in use in
kentucky and b was there a ruling as to
whether they were slot machines or not
the answer is yes they're still abuse in
kentucky as as i i'm aware
and
the answer is they just didn't comply
with the prime mutual law that i don't
think the court said that there were
slot machines and not slot machines they
just said they were not authorized
gambling under their mutual law so it's
a
it doesn't fit your question very well
charlie i have a question for you yes
sir difference between a slot machine
and a historic racing machine
um
the fundamental difference is the math
and the back so if you ask the question
if they would and i don't like to use
the word slot machine because it's not
an accurate description of technology
slot machine
refers actually to a slot that used to
be in 1960s machines so they don't
really use that language anymore but to
your question
um
it's slower
version of gambling
the winning experience is not the same
as a slot machine so the velocity is
slower
the winning experience is different
because you're winning off of a power
mutual you're not winning off of a pay
table so
i can describe a pig table looks like a
pyramid the top prize and then down
a historic horse racing machine you win
based off the odds of a horse race and
so
you're not going to get things like a
slot machines you're also not going to
get a near win which is also very
popular in slot machines
and so when you look at a tax rate or a
commission rate of 25 percent
if this was a thousand slot machines
the tax rate would be 50 percent and i
so and there would be a license fee of
20 million and somebody be thrilled to
pay it so
they're not as economically beneficial
or popular so therefore
that's why the percentage is what it is
because they're just not as
thank you charlie
further questions uh representative uh
bernstein
thank you mr chair
hi charlie
um the
honorable neil kirk who testified prior
to you
said that this bill
practically invites fraud
how would the lottery
ensure that charities get the portion of
the proceeds that they're supposed to
get
not only for historic racing but for
charitable gaming in general
well certainly thank you for the
question representative um
currently fundamentally there are 10
employees who engage
almost exclusively on charitable
gambling now
uh we have three investigators but what
we did is we hired
well soon to be five financial auditors
who audited the books of the charities
that are the books or the gaming
yeah uh operator employers
um and what we found we do that because
i'll use the example so the irs when
they hire criminal investigators they
hire accountants because they're good at
counting money
similarly we wanted to focus on auditing
the rooms and making sure the numbers
were correct versus investigators who
really look for conduct
at the facility and so
that's one way we beefed up i mean i
think we're probably three times more
than we were
when we inherited this four years ago we
didn't inherit it we were told to take
it over
and also
are much easier to audit
because you can actually access them in
real time through a site control that
exists in the facility that we can
access through a back office system and
review in real time the amount of money
in question
and really since we've taken this over
every single charitable gaming operator
has been audited within the last two
years
and that's a program we installed just
recently but we will be doing that on an
ongoing basis
and then certainly when we first took
this agency over
i sent out i think it was 500 subpoenas
to everybody that had anything to do at
any point in time with every aspect of
charitable gambling to try and get all
of the numbers from every aspect of it
to make sure that indeed everyone was
getting what they were supposed to do or
supposed to get
and we found that to be the case with
very minor discrepancies we found that
representative elliott
yes thank you mr chairman it's the same
question
that i asked and i heard the first half
of the answer
i asked who
does the lottery commission
pick the charities and
mr mcintyre's answer was no but i didn't
hear the second part of it
if
if he they don't do it who picks the
charities that are going to get the
money i didn't hear his answer
oh i'm sorry representative if i wasn't
speaking clearly um the operator of the
the facility chooses the charities
and currently there are waiting lists i
think in every facility now
to become a charity that benefits from
this
so
anymore because i think the list is
already full
that answers the question the operator
of the facility
the charity
yes
over
thank you mr chairman uh charlie i know
that you can't
from your position come out in favor or
opposed to any particular bill but could
you tell us
what you feel about
the progress we might make
with helping out charities by putting
this hhs system in
i mean represent ober thank you for the
question certainly i believe we will
increase revenue significantly towards
charities and i will tell you as a
personal matter as a professional for
the agency
we're always fans of technology
it's a whole lot easier to
manage than people
are
and you know would you
any issue you've seen in terms of audits
has largely been around people and money
but if this technology and as you see in
the bill there's testing through a
certified laboratory and the ability to
randomly test machines will
it's much more manageable than there is
sort of people and money that's all so
we're quite comfortable with it
thank you
uh further questions
saying then we can go back
to our
testifiers mr chair looks like
representative ducette has his hand up
sorry about that mr chair and i'll i'll
be real brief while we have charlie live
um i'm wondering if you saw uh the pie
chart that representative of brahmi
uh presented in his testimony when he
was uh presenting this bill this morning
and if those numbers the way they are
broken down
uh specific to what percentages go to
the state the charities the operator
etc if if that drives in your mind
because uh
i'm curious if you've seen that
i have representative thank you for the
question uh that's correct yes
um
the operator doesn't get to keep all
that money obviously there's significant
capital costs and he has to split it
with the machine
operator the individual brings the
technology in and has to build out the
infrastructure um and usually that's not
on a ref share basis so the manufacturer
of the store horse racing machines it's
a percentage of the
uh the the the whole so
it's not 75 percent doesn't go to the
further questions
you're all set representative
yes mr chair thank you
yeah um
good afternoon
uh this this is a question i was i was
looking back uh to the previous year and
to the
blurb or
report on the bill from
ways and means when it came to the floor
and uh
at the end of the blurb uh
there's a statement about concern that
uh
the competition from encore
will uh
in massachusetts the big casino
uh is threatening um charitable revenues
and that's that's essentially put
forward as one of the reasons for
needing to sort of expand the base
for um
charitable gaming
and the proceeds that result from it
um so uh
how is charitable gaming doing these
days competition from encore has uh
shriveled away so far anyway i think but
how are we doing
certainly um thank you for the question
initially when the encore opened there
was a significant loss of charitable
gambling revenue um related largely to
card games because they had such a large
marketing budget unable to sort of
entice players down there
certainly with covid the mass gaming
commission is far more restrictive than
related to facilities like that and so
it's hard to draw an accurate comparison
of where we are versus them because
they are greater restrictions in terms
of how many folks can be in the facility
how close they can be
than we are um certainly so it's
it's an incomplete answer i guess best
way to describe it at ames we certainly
noticed an impact up front uh and since
kovid it's the opposite and i don't know
what it looks like postcode
okay if i may uh follow up
yeah um
so putting aside encore
the
question is uh how are revenue i i
probably couldn't look this up myself
but you're on top of it
um
how is the revenue situation looking
for charitable gaming
this year will be higher than last year
significantly i don't have the number in
front of me honestly
but i can get that for you if you want
and can you explain why that is
because they're they'll the sort of the
the competition is closed or hat was
closed
materially and
and sort of in reality is closed
in boston
and springfield's too far away
um and really oxford is an awkward
position to get to
even though they sponsor this mile where
i'm in you folks the state house are
there's not the same dramatic pull to
oxford as there is to
encore and connecticut
i will tell you that when we do research
we see those as the facilities folks go
to and not oxford maine
okay thank you
okay
i don't see any other hands
so
we'll go to
the next one jerry strangham
a
former legislator
member of the public and representing
thank you uh chairman major uh vice
chairman of rami
and uh congratulations on your elevation
to clerk representative bursting
and this is getting to your right it's
great to see what the left side of your
face actually looks like
i see that i got to see your good side
but things always look better when you
look
you know
that's nice to see my democratic
colleagues as well uh representative
albany ames
gamarlo
malloy
and tucker
i think i saw laughlin there earlier too
my name is jerry stringham and i'm
pleased to have been following the
greatest deliberative body in the new
hampshire legislature
with the great leaders of both parties
and uh listen to many things so far i
think you're off to a great start
i have to say i really appreciate the
kind words
at earlier hearings meant a lot to me
regarding house bill 626 first of all
there was an extensive amount of time
spent in the last
last biennium on the predecessor bills
first let me summarize the difference
between historic racing and slots
experientially we know there's barely a
dime's worth of difference between the
two
we saw it ourselves on demonstrations
that showed this how similar they are
it was extensive discussions that
demonstrate the equivalent of products
with the same unwanted addictive
properties as slots
this is a backdoor effort to infiltrate
our state with many casinos
uh that's just what uh i see it as
um
uh if you do wanna move forward with
slot like machines
uh the economics of the arrangements in
this bill are horrible
with this bill the state
state is gaining a small percentage as
you heard about 16 percent of the take
the charity is about 9
it's a bad deal for our states and
charities uh charlie mcintyre uh last
biennium and direct answered a question
uh uh indicated that offered a contract
bid for slots he would get a substantial
fee
plus about 55 percent of the take he
said pretty much the same thing here
today
i did look up in maryland's slot
percentage is 61
i understand
so to support representative laughlin's
point
lachman's point i would if we're going
to create all the problems that come
with slots you should just get slots and
get a better deal
uh if we wanted um we could then set up
a charitable business fee assuming
the license was not already being sold
to an existing
this bill allows gambling on slot like
slot machine like machines for 18 year
olds has been mentioned
our neighboring states have a 21 year
old restriction on casinos we're going
to attract people here
i think the 25 betting limit is way too
high
in
my objections um last time um go ahead
and
tell a story about
my objection to slot machines in general
or slot
uh machines that operate like slot
machines
in terms of whether we want to have
historic racing or slots in our town let
alone our state i'm going to tell you a
story from a constituent
who's not still a friend of mine here
which i have permission to share
his wife's gambling problems destroyed
his marriage
her habits wiped out most of the
couple's savings and he couldn't escape
it
efforts to divorce were were contested
and difficult
he moved from massachusetts to lincoln
in part to escape that
and support his interests his son's
interest in aerial ski jumping
because he was still married as a
strange wife new credit card bills and
depths kept coming back to him for a
while he was able to get her to quit uh
while the divorce
process lingered
well then encore was going to show up
only a few miles from where she lived
he knew she she couldn't resist he took
the painful step to bring her to grafton
county
if either historic racing or slots show
up here
he's moving he's not here anymore
he is living next to a hand grenade with
a pin removed and his historic racing
will provide the jolt to blow up his
world again
he's asking
to preserve the special nature of the
granite state is a no slot machine no
as as a word of thought and perhaps
advice i would like to recommend to the
sponsors to just try to advance a bill
that is slot machines
the this effort that we went through two
years in a row to use historic horse
racing will have this committee and the
legislature spinning in a stationary
carousel
lots and lots and lots of motion and no
movement
you will also make far better use of the
huge intellect in this committee and the
new hampshire house and totally get rid
of this infuriating semantical argument
of whether historic racing machines are
similar
in terms of this backdoor effort to
introduce casinos into the state due to
its legalization of a technology long
believed to be dangerous
uh turning our state for
as a welcome with a welcome mat for
under 21 year old gamblers
incredibly poor economics for the state
and the charity for historic race device
of this type
for gross unfairness to pre-selecting
who can and
cannot get these systems
and the lack of say by local communities
i
i don't support this bill in this
current structure
i strongly urge a body to continue to
strengthen our charitable gaming
businesses first by analysis and then
means other than historic racing like
the bill i heard earlier today
thank you very much
thank you very much for your testimony
honorable spam
questions
none okay
all right thank you we'll go on to the
next
testifier
patrick neely
is a member of the public he's from the
this bill
mr chairman can you hear me
yes
very good
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is patrick neely i'm
from exacta systems it's good to be
in front of this committee again
just briefly xacta systems we are the
the leading technology and systems
provider in the historic horse racing
space
we're currently in several jurisdictions
including kentucky
uh wyoming and virginia
so a lot has been said about historic
horse racing obviously a lot has been
said uh as i've testified in front of
your committee on numerous occasions
before so i'll just briefly go through a
description of historic horse racing and
then we'd be happy
to answer any questions um
there are two main elements of historic
horse racing and the bill sponsor
representative abrami did a good job of
going through those the the first is
that it is a paramutual wager
so a pair mutual wager means that all of
the participants are betting against
each other
you're not betting against the house and
that is a key distinction again
as the discussion goes between is this a
slot machine is it not a slot machine it
is most definitely not a slot machine
and that's one of the key distinctions
a paramutual wager means that you are
wagering against all of your fellow
players
when you're betting at a slot machine
you are betting against the house
so the way a paramutual wager works is
the operator takes a commission on each
wager
the rest of the money is placed into a
paramutual pool and is redistributed to
winning handicappers
this is exactly like live and
simulcasting works which is currently
the second part of
paramutual wagering on historic horse
racing is that it is a bet on a horse
race so again just like a live and a
simulcast bet which is currently legal
in the state of new hampshire
you are betting on the outcome of a
horse race so a random number generator
determines the outcome of a slot machine
wager
this wager is determined by the outcome
of horse races so
if you are a good handicapper
you have a better chance of winning your
wager just like a live or a simulcast
bet if you went to a racetrack or an otb
facility and we're betting on a horse
race you have the ability to determine
whether your wager is a winning wager or
not based on the skill of your
handicapping
so those are the two
primary um
distinguishing
factors
for historic horse racing it is a pair
mutual bet on the outcome of a horse
race
and it is very much like what is
currently legal in the state of new
hampshire paramutual wagers on the
outcome of horse races
so
obviously a lot ahead of discussion has
already taken place on is this a slot
machine is it not a slot machine again
those two key distinctions that i talked
about will tell you that it is not a
slot machine but another thing can tell
you that it is not a slot machine
there are
hundreds if not thousands of tribal and
commercial casinos represented
in throughout the country and actually
throughout the world
and at not one single uh one of those
casinos either tribal or commercial will
you find a historic horse racing
terminal not not one there is not one
hhr terminal on the floor of any casino
anywhere in the united states or the
world
so the question is why not if if these
were slot machines i think you would
expect to find them right next to their
slot machine brethren on the floor of a
casino and
i think there are a lot of reasons why
you will not find them there
obviously because they're not slot
machines a lot of key distinctions
number one they're slower um a lot of
people have already talked about that
today but they go
they go slower than slot machines first
of all you have the horse races that
you're betting on
uh you have handicapping information
that you can look at
you can look at past races uh you can
order the four order your projected
order of finish
uh once the races go off you actually
look at the uh
a replay of the finish of the race and
then after that
you can look at that past performances
of the horses the official order of
finish of the of the particular races so
this is
second i would argue that hhr terminals
are probably much fairer to the player
than our slot machines when you're
playing a slot machine
you are playing a device that the casino
owns and frankly they hope that you lose
because you're playing against them if
you lose the casino wins and vice versa
when you sit down to play an hhr machine
you are not playing against the operator
you're not playing against the house
you're playing against your fellow
patrons
the operator takes their commission and
they don't have an incentive for you to
lose in fact they don't really care
whether you win or lose because they've
taken their commission
to put forth a pair mutual pool
and from there it's based on your skill
as a handicapper
whether you're going to win or whether
you're gonna lose your wager
and and and that last part i think is a
is a is a key distinction
the outcome of your bet is up to you um
you can be a good historic horse racing
player you can be a good handicapper
it is impossible to be a good slot
machine player slot machines are
determined at random your bet is
determined at random
but as a handicapper just like in live
or simulcast racing you can be a good
handicapper you can take the time to
look at the statistics order your
projected order of finish and if you're
right if you're good
you can be a better player than the
person sitting next to you and in fact
you're going to win more of the
paramutual pool than the players sitting
next to you because you're a better
player so
it's this fairness it's this ability to
control
what you're wagering on and the outcome
that is a key distinction
so yes the the terminals the way that
they're housed those that does resemble
a slot machine but what is inside the
way the bets work the way that the bets
function the pair mutual nature those
are all radically different from slot
machines
and
a representative
earlier raised the issue that well hhr
machines are where slot machines can't
be um and i i want to i want to clarify
that
um
every jurisdiction that historic horse
racing is legal
except for kentucky slot machines are
also legal so
in oregon there are i believe 14 tribal
casinos where slot machines are legal
historic horse racing is also legal in
the state of oregon you will not find a
single hhr machine in any of those
tribal facilities in oregon
the same is in wyoming
hhr is legal in the state of wyoming
there are tribal facilities in the state
of wyoming you will not find a single
hhr machine on those tribal in those
tribal casinos the same in arkansas
casino gaming is legal in arkansas hhr
is legal in arkansas
you won't find an hhr machine in a
casino there same as in virginia casino
gaming was just passed in virginia you
will not find an hhr machine in any of
the new
casinos in virginia and again the
question is why not and and we've just
explained because they're really not
competitive they're not the same product
and frankly they're not a competitive
product with slot machines they're
slower
they're fairer
and they're paramutual in nature
uh finally i'd just like to talk about
kentucky uh mr mcintyre briefly talked
about that uh kentucky is my home state
i'm very familiar with this litigation
as mr mcintyre said it was based on the
statutory interpretation of prayer
mutual under kentucky law i'd like to
clarify for the members of the committee
the kentucky legislature did not
authorize historic horse racing via
statute it was originally authorized via
regulation by the kentucky horse racing
commission
so in essence what the kentucky supreme
court said is
if uh you're we are going to shoehorn
historic horse racing under the
definition of peer mutual
under kentucky statute then the
legislature needs to redefine paramutual
to include historic horse racing so
that's the key distinction obviously
it's a moot point as you are considering
legislation uh to include historic horse
racing under peer mutual so uh
what was at issue in the kentucky case
uh is moot as it relates to your
consideration here today
uh with that mr chairman i'll wrap it up
and again we'll be happy to answer any
questions on how the system and machines
work or anything else as it pertains to
historic horse racing
thank you mr neely on your testimony
and when um this uh horse racing comes
up do you know the names of the horses
that are there so they can always bet on
seabiscuit
yeah
no no so we we redact any identifying
information when we give you
handicapping statistics we remove the
names of the horses the names of the
jockey the name of the racetrack where
the race took place uh the date that
that it took place
uh so that you obviously can't get on
your phone and look up well what race
this was and who won it um so those
identifying factors are removed uh but
again we give you statistics
handicapping statistics
uh that allows you to make uh exercise
your skill and judgment and make your
handicapping decision uh as you order
your projected order of finish but
instead of
instead of seabiscuit it's horse number
one
follow up mr chair paul
but the statistics on the uh horse are
provided that is whether it's a mutter
whether it's a a dry track or a turf
horse
gender it's a record
that that that that is correct that is
correct so you can't identify the horse
but we we provide you with handicapping
statistics like
uh yeah
jockey rating at the at the current
distance and on the track surface uh
or post position wind percentage at this
particular track and distance and
surface uh things of that nature
uh so that you can make an educated
decision
uh when you make your handicapping
selections
any further questions uh yes
representative ames followed by
representatives
thank you um
so mr neely
uh
are you able to
tell me what percent of the dollar value
of bets placed on historic racing
machines whether
by statewide or
in the country however you want to
answer this
are placed by
we we don't have those numbers i don't
have those percentages um so let me talk
a little bit about the auto play feature
in our system it's called auto cap that
means that's short for auto handicapping
so
what this allows the handicapper to do
is accept the off odds of the horse race
when the horse race went off when it was
originally run say 15 years ago
so this allows handicappers to employ a
relatively common betting strategy which
is what we call in the racing business
betting the tote board so you're betting
the favorite to win
you bet the favorite to win and you bet
the second choice of the betting public
to run second and you bet the third
choice of the betting public to run
third
so if you go to a racetrack or an otb
facility today you will see
a lot of people employing that
handicapping strategy um you bet the
favorite you bet the favorite to win so
that's what autocap allows the
handicapper to do is basically bet the
tote board now if the player doesn't
want to bet the tote board and wants to
make their own decisions that they think
that the betting favorite is
uh a false favorite shouldn't be the
favorite then they get the ability to
reorder their projected order of finish
so again just like a live or simulcast
race um but that that is what the auto
cap feature does and uh that's how
that's how it functions but
but i don't have the percentage of uh of
how many people use auto cap and how
many people don't
oh
yeah
[Music]
that's surprising to me that you
wouldn't have that data like that
is that because it's
technically difficult to obtain or you
just don't collect that data
yeah we we do not track it uh that's
just not something that is reported in
our system um
what is reported in our system and kind
of following up on an oversight question
that was raised before
uh every wager that is placed is tracked
in real time um and is auditable and is
reported uh at the end of every day to
uh the the regulators as i said we're
we are operational in virginia kentucky
and wyoming currently so at the end of
every day our system generates
a voluminous report that goes to the
various regulators
uh that actually can go down to a bet by
bet uh examination of what took place
during that day so the regulators are
able every morning to look exactly how
much money was wagered into a pure
mutual pool how much money was won out
of a pair mutual pool
right down to the machine level how much
money was wagered on a specific hhr
terminal
so again all of that is produced on a
daily basis
and is easily
easily formatted so that the regulators
can see exactly what's taking place
uh
every day on the hhr floors
we should have one more follow up follow
up
many
who have commented on historic racing
during the time that i've been
following this debate um
say
that uh and maybe they're uninformed to
say that uh
that most
players something like that most players
use the autoplay feature
um is that wrong
uh uh no i don't believe so i would say
that a majority of people use autocap
but i will tell you that a significant
number of people
uh enjoy the handicapping features and
definitely take advantage of that as
well
representative
dussette thank you mr chairman and thank
you mr nealy for taking my question and
it's good to hear you again sir uh
in in brief uh there was an assertion
made that there's some sort of uh random
number generating component of uh
with hhr machines maybe you can explain
a little better how the next race is
generated in in that
is it is it comparable
to the way a slot machine operates or is
it
in fact uh
maybe you can describe it better if you
know what i'm getting at is is there a
component of random generation of any
sort of uh sure end of this thank you
yeah so let me clarify that so
random number generator is kind of a
buzzword in the the slot machine world
because that that is how an at the
outcome of a wager is determined right
it's determined at random so an rng is
in the device and it determines whether
this player is going to win this
particular spin historic horse racing
terminals do not have that
the outcome is not determined at random
your wager is won or lost based on the
results of the horse race and your
handicapping ability whether you got it
right or got it wrong
so we do have a library of roughly 100
000 historic horse races and so when a
player wants to bet on a historic horse
race
three in our system three races are
pulled from that from that database and
presented to the player
so that that's how the system works we
also have an alternative where uh
uh the
historic horse races are actually
scheduled at the beginning of the day
um and they run through uh until
wagering closes for that day um
so again there are there are two ways to
base quote unquote schedule what races
are going to be wagered on uh by
historic horse racing handicappers
hopefully representative do set that
clears it up a little bit thank you yes
it did thank you
thank you miss
oh thank you mr chair
you you're talking about auto cap i
assume you're talking about automatic
handicapping
and it's my understanding that this
particular feature applies to a large
number of sports besides horse racing i
think that applies to golf football
basketball
baseball
and golfing
where you can
determine uh either your handicap for
your scoring purposes
or your the handicap
for
uh
betting purposes uh on these various
could you describe what automatic
handicapping is
or give us a link as to some place to
describe it or find it
to to better understand it because store
i hear one person saying that it's a
skill activity yourself i hear another
person saying that it's a random
generation of facts and figures
sure so uh handicapping is uh i think
the generally accepted nomenclature of
uh people who are trying to predict the
outcome of a particular race now
golf and other sports uh
not related to us we we don't we don't
do any of that um
so handicapping is the art of trying to
accurately select the outcome of a horse
race so you're if if i'm when i go to
the track and i'm placing my bets i'm
i'm a handicapper and i'm handicapping
the race i'm trying to determine who's
going to win who's going to run second
who's going to run third
so there are lots of handicapping
strategies that people employ
as i mentioned earlier one of the most
popular ones is betting on the favorite
so some people will not look at the
racing form
uh their handicapping strategy is to bet
on whoever the favorite is in the race
that's their handicapping strategy
some people's handicapping strategy is
to bet on their lucky number or the
favorite color of their jockey silks
that's how they handicap the race
so when i talk about auto handicapping
in our system i'm talking about the
first handicapping strategy that i
discussed which is betting the favorites
so it automatically orders the horses
from favorite to long shot and you're
betting on the tote board so
uh that that is what that is what we're
talking about when we're talking about
auto handicapping you are making the
decision as a handicapper
to bet the favorite to win to bet the
second place horse to run second all the
way down to the longest shot on the
board to run last
so that that
that that's that is what handicapping
means in the horse racing world and that
is what auto handicapping means in our
system
questions
representing
yeah thank you just one last question on
this autoplay
matter um can you tell me how uh
how much time lapses
uh
has to lapse
between
uh plays bets if when using the auto
play feature how how frequently
within a minute or uh
how many seconds does it take to go from
one bit to the next when you're
determined to just hit that button
yeah it is so again it depends on the
player um so if you're trying to
not look at any uh any other information
if you want to ignore
uh your
the past performance chart if you want
to ignore the official results of the
race if you don't want to look at the
replay if your goal is to do it as fast
as you can is that that's what you're
asking
yeah yeah it's pr it's probably four to
five seconds depending um again
uh unlike a slot machine which can give
you a result in about a quarter or a
half of a second this is a pair mutual
bet on a horse race so when you place
the bet the tote system has to evaluate
your wager it has to evaluate uh the
finishing order of the race it has to
evaluate whether your
wager is a winning one and then it has
to evaluate what percentage of the
paramutual pool you're going to receive
so
all of that is taking place behind the
scene
uh in the tote and so that is why hhr is
significantly slower than um than a
traditional slot machine so i i would
say probably five seconds maybe six um
if you really wanted to go as quickly as
you could
okay that's helpful four to six seconds
is my take away
thank
you thank you mr chairman um kind of
following up on the timing issue there
if you decide to manually handicap um
each race
is there does the machine
cause you to move along quickly or does
it give you as much time as you need or
how does that work yeah so it depends on
the setting it's configurable and it
depends on the jurisdiction if there are
any jurisdictional requirements um
in most jurisdictions where we're
operating we give people between 30
seconds and a minute per race um to make
their handicapping decision and and
again we have three races that you're
wagering on at a time so
anywhere from a minute and a half to
three minutes um again that can be
configurable um
what we you know don't want to do is
give a player so much time uh again that
this is an event that took place uh
already so the you know the answer is
out there um
so
what we we don't want to do is give a
player two hours to try to figure out
you know what what particular race this
was um so we we feel like there needs to
be some reasonable time limitation
uh in order to give people enough time
to handicap look at the statistics uh
but not so much time that they could
attempt to uh game the system
follow up mr chairman oh
so you're you're picking three races and
how many horses are you handicapping
what three three horses in each race
yeah
there are different systems are
different in ours most of the wagers
you're gonna win
the top two the top three are the top
four horses in those races so you're
either trying to handy
6 12 or 18 finishing positions uh
depending on what peer mutual uh pool
you are wagering into
any further questions
thank you mr neely
thank you sir next i'm going to call
upon
a james dunces
would you on
i'm trying to find this person maybe
they could raise their hand out there
there we go
hello mr chair
oh can you hear me yes okay well thank
you very much for entertaining our
testimony
i wanted to testify in favor of the bill
because for a couple of basic reasons
the charitable gaining gaming sites are
providing very vital
support for the non-profits
that and i'm sure that you and the
members of the committee are very
familiar with the
range of needs that the non-profits
help to address but homelessness and
kids in need the boys and girls club
uh the girls inc
shelters for families you know all just
everything
and
those non-profits have you know really
rely on the support that comes from the
charitable gaming sites
and now during the pandemic
that support is even more important
because the traditional
fundraising activities which most
non-profits engage in
have been very you know very curtailed
you know there aren't
galas or dinners or a lot of fundraising
events those can't be held
so the non-profits excuse me the
charitable gaming sites have become even
even more important
this will help the charitable gaming
sites to
realize more revenue for charitable
gaming
and really will bring more people into
the charitable gaming sites so that
those same people could you know risk
money on a
or something else that uh is also there
so for those reasons i and i know many
mo you know many charities many
non-profits in our
region are very much for this
uh secondly some of the money as the
sponsor testified will also be going
into the
uh educational trust fund
never enough money is in the educational
trust fund there's a lot of support that
schools need even now during the
pandemic that's become more acute
so i'm asking the committee to
act favorably on this bill so that we
can
provide even more support during a very
critical time and beyond even beyond the
pandemic
for the good work of the nonprofits that
and if you have questions i'd of course
be glad to answer them
but that concludes my testimony mr chair
any questions for the mayor
the next
one thank you very much mr chair
we thank you
it's from
michael
afflebark he's got his hands raised
yes good afternoon mr chairman good
afternoon members of the house ways and
means committee
you're testifying and support right yes
sir i am my name yes i am my name is
mike affelberg and i am the president of
the united way of greater nashua and i
do come to you today in favor of h.b 626
seeking to expand charitable gaming to
include historic horse racing
uh as a community organization we don't
take this endorsement lightly we are
concerned about the negative
consequences of gaming addiction
and the need for mental health supports
for those who are affected by this
particular disease
that said and to set our minds at ease
we've had conversations with local
mental health providers including those
representing greater nashua mental
health and harbor care to to determine
if the presence of charitable gaming in
our community has contributed in in any
significant way to gaming addiction in
the community we've been assured that
this has not been the case
it is our feeling that historic horse
racing with its emphasis on wagering
bets on actual races already run is not
significantly more addictive than other
types of gaming including card games
and less addictive likely than pure
games of chance such as roulette which
already exist in our charitable gaming
houses
therefore we see more potential
benefits to allowing the presence of
historical or horse racing as it
pertains specifically to the non-profit
supports in our community
over the past few years we've been
indirect
we at united way have been the direct
recipients of these donations along with
dozens and dozens of other local
nonprofits
by my estimation
the largest grant making supporters of
nonprofit work in our community include
the new hampshire charitable foundation
the city of nashua and united way
when each of us makes a grant to a local
non-profit we put any number of
stipulations on those funds and this is
important because it means that those
funds are restricted to specific
activities and specific outcomes
that can also be said for state and
federal funding however
importantly funds received from
charitable gaming are similar to most
individual donations and that they are
unrestricted
what that means to a non-profit in the
is that these funds can be used for any
number of types of expenses including
utilities payroll paying the rent
supporting volunteers etc
in our case we've used these
unrestricted dollars in many cases to
support our covid19 emergency relief
efforts
because of the
unrestricted
uses of those funds without the
flexibility of unrestricted funding
exactly like that which comes from
charitable gaming those efforts could be
crippled
one aspect of the bill we appreciate is
its emphasis on keeping the dollars
within the executive council district
in other words local dollars stay local
this is a good thing and very much
mirrors our emphasis at united way
with almost 400 registered non-profits
in greater nashua in good standing we
feel that the need is very strong in our
community because of these points low
likely incidents of increased gaming
addiction
significant unrestricted dollars
emphasis on local community we support
and endorse the passage of 626. thank
you very much thank you for your
testimony mr ashberg any questions from
the committee
all right
wrap it in uh
long run
yes thank you mr chairman i i had a
question actually uh from mr bragdon is
that
possible mr brighton uh no churchill
downs
yeah
yeah we need to uh ask a question for
the person testifying and then
we can try to locate them later
okay questions for
no question for him then thank you
representative
thank you
um
thank you for testifying i just had a
quick question or it's actually kind of
a couple questions i'm assuming um do
you all already take advantage of the 10
yes we have taken advantage of the 10
days of charitable gaming that we get
sometimes it's 7 days sometimes it's 10
days
that of course is entirely up to the
gaming
um
operator themselves but we certainly do
and if i can ask a follow-up i'm curious
thank you i'm curious to um
[Music]
so i used to run a non-profit and i'm
i'm curious to get your feedback your
thoughts on the 35 of the two dollars
that you would share with the state um
would you
i mean it's a silly question because of
course i'm sure you want more but can
you kind of give a um
an idea to the committee of you know
what do you do with the that 70 cents
that you're gonna get and how how do you
do you wish you could get more i mean i
i
it's a silly question of course but can
you share what you do with that 70 cents
of those two dollars
well um
so of course it's not a silly question
to say do i wish we got more because of
course we wish we got more but um
that said we're also uh very grateful
for what we do get and i'm sure as a as
a prior executive director and a
non-profit you would you can appreciate
that as well
um what we do is so our every of course
every nonprofit is different
our united way um
is as pretty efficient 87 of the money
that we raise actually goes toward the
work we do in the community and less
than two percent of the money we raise
actually exits the community for any
reason that those are pretty pretty good
numbers so we put it to work doing any
number of things
typically we use it to make grants to
our non-profit partners
during our during the covid period we've
also made over 50 emergency grants we've
purchased and distributed over 400
wireless hotspots to local students
we've distributed 600 laptops 200 000
face masks the list kind of goes on and
on the the the thing that i'd like to
share with people is that we're able to
do that type of work with this kind of
funding because the funding is
unrestricted meaning it does allow us to
be flexible in making a difference in
our community in the ways in which our
our impact measurements
would direct us versus getting a grant
from the city or state or
federal government that says
you need to spend it on this thing and
this thing alone
so that's how this funding is used
differently i hope that answers your
question yes thank you any further
questions
uh
representative molloy we have 10 more
speakers after this
thank you mr chairman uh
very quickly
i'm i was
my professional life was fundraising
um
i'm interested in
how
one how how but i never relied on
charitable gaming
how does an organization budget
for uh the va the very variances from
year to year
that may accompany that kind of money i
understand the unrestricted part of this
and that's very valuable i get that
but that amount can change from year to
year and if you get in line if you're
not in line and all that how does that
how do you account for those changes
from year to year in what you might
expect from charitable gaming
thank you representative molloy that is
actually an outstanding question we um
generally speaking budget these dollars
extraordinarily conservatively
and
frankly this year we've been glad of
that practice seeing how
institutions have been open been closed
in restricted capacity etc
our budgeting our budgeting
is for no more than 50 of what we
received in the prior year
and that's
and if we receive more we're um
astonished and grateful
but i also recommend to all of our
nonprofit partners don't budget high on
these dollars because you know what
there's a reason why they call it
gambling it's gambling and
um there are a lot of there are a lot of
um reasons why those dollars can change
covet is the frankly the last of them
that we ever thought about the first of
them is you're at the
you're really um at the mercy of the
gaming operator to decide whether you
are going to be recipient at all
and to what extent you're going to
receive days and then of course you have
what those days are
so we try to be conservative with that
and i recommend to everybody to be
conservative with that
thank you any further questions
saying none that i'm going to ask for
the next next person to testify is a
michael
carrigan
he has his hand raised hi good afternoon
mr chairman can you hear me
yes
hi mr chairman thank you very much i'd
like to also thank the committee members
for hearing my testimony today my name
is michael carrignon and i am testifying
in support of house bill 626
i am currently the police of chief chief
of police for the nashua police
department but i'm also speaking to you
today as a
board member for several non-profits in
nashville i currently sit on the boards
for national pal margarites place
nationals community conversation on race
and justice as well as a couple others
and speaking on behalf
from the from the lens of a non-profit
board member um i'll reiterate what
mayor jim doncha said we live and die
off of the money that we get through
fundraising
we have to struggle to have different
events
we compete with over 250 non-profits in
nashville we're all competing for the
same dollars for those of you who've
testified who've run boards or been on
boards you understand the difficulty of
that and trying to all get along trying
to solicit people for the same funds
that can be very challenging
the charitable gaming aspect
has been a windfall and
a survival mechanism especially for the
last
the last year during this covid crisis
all other fundraisers dried up typical
funds that were coming in every year the
fundraisers weren't able to be had
because of covert restrictions
we've been able to with the charitable
gaming survive quite frankly and that
money has been able to
help keep the programs running and keep
the people in need running those
programs
i'd like to talk real quick about my
role as a police chief in my perspective
from that lens because i think
it's a unique perspective and you need
to understand it
as a police chief as you've heard all
the
noise across the country about law
enforcement reform and the need for
social workers to be participating more
in
how how people are helped through mental
health
substance misuse domestic violence
assault sexual assault victims
we as police officers respond to the
immediacy of those situations and what
that means is we get a call we go and
handle it
and we basically make sure everybody is
safe
at that time what we then do is we do
what we call a warm handoff to a social
service agency for the experts that can
handle it in nashua as many communities
those social service agencies are
non-profits bridges is our domestic
violence sexual assault specialists we
have margarites places transitional
housing for young women we have pal
which gets kids connected with police
officers back in the community doing
homework doing school work and getting
mentorship there are just like i said
over 200 charities in nashua that we use
to help us do our jobs the state of new
hampshire
can't afford to pay social workers for
all the different types of situations
that come
come across our my desk on a daily basis
all the needs of all the people
the nonprofits in nashville do that we
have those relationships with them so
when we handle something immediately we
have an opportunity to get them to the
experts to get people the help that they
need at really very little cost to the
state and that's something you all need
to to remember these are volunteer
dollars going to nonprofits that do the
work that the state would have to do to
keep all these people and give them the
resources they need
so i i would appreciate that that
perspective that you take into account
how valuable those nonprofits are and
how necessary that charitable gaming is
for us to run those um as as i'm
testifying i believe you're all
receiving an email containing a very
short two-minute video from marguerite's
place i would ask that at some point
today you take two minutes to watch the
video just to kind of see the impact
that the non-profits have on real people
in my community every day so i
appreciate the time i'll answer any
questions
thank you for your testimony mr
carradine
any questions
saying none i do i do
i do
representative doucet mr chairman okay
representative
real quick and i'll make it real quick
uh thank you chief uh
kerrigan for your testimony thank you
for taking my question and more
importantly thank you for your service
to to your uh
your community and more specifically to
the charities they're in and even more
specifically to the end users
um
just a quick question because i've heard
it before and it hasn't come up in
discussion thus far and it may come up
again
um i know you've been in law enforcement
for many many years and we've heard a
number of times that uh charitable
gaming or gaming in in general can put a
strain on on policing um
and
an increase on call volume etc have you
experienced anything of the sort in in
nashua or in your experience as a law
enforcement officer chief thank you
thank you for the question sir i've been
a police officer for about 28 years and
we haven't had turtle gaming that whole
time but we've had them in nashville we
now have three gaming facilities and
they're spread out through three
different
dynamics economic dynamics within the
city some downtown some out in in
quieter sectors we have not had any
increase in call volume to any of them
nor have we had an increase to any types
of calls for those in fact i'd say it's
quite the opposite i think um the the
active participation that they have
has helped us
the the community partners that they are
has actually lowered our lowered our
costs and lowered our responses because
it affords us the opportunity to work
like i was saying before to some of the
more nonprofits and let them get to the
again thank you chief thank you anybody
else pushing to speak i don't see any
raised hands
at this point
so then the next one to testify
is tony
de generio
he's a member of the public representing
the new hampshire philharmonic orchestra
and he supports it he says
and then i'm looking can you raise his
hand please
i have one phone number here i don't
i do not see his name
[Music]
so we'll go to the next one okay
the next one is tina
a member of the public from the home
health and hospice care
supports the bill and meets three
minutes
there she goes
good afternoon can you hear me yes we
can thank you so much for having me here
today
i'm from home health and hospice care
we're a non-profit visiting nurse
association and hospice we own the
community hospice house in merrimack
now one of only two hospice houses in
the state
for well over a century our mission has
been to care for people whatever their
financial circumstances
and many of our patients come to us
without insurance or resources
we rely on the generosity of a caring
community to do our work
but it is always a challenge
i hardly need to tell you
that this last year
has been more challenging
especially at the hospice house
where we believe that dying patients
should be able to hold the hands of
their loved ones as life comes to a
close
thankfully we have been able
to facilitate that mercy
because of the large contribution
from our week of charitable gaming
that bought
the expensive
and extensive
amount of ppe's that have been necessary
to protect our line staff
while still allowing family members
to visit the bedside
as we speak today
hams at the community hospice house are
still being held and memories are being
made
and not through
a glass window
the contribution from our neighborhood
casino
boston billiards
came in a year when all of our
fundraising events had to be cancelled
the money we gratefully received
directly impacted families
all over our service area
we have all been through an
extraordinary
time of trial
and to meet this trial
we need lawmakers who will recognize the
moment and the urgency
i most sincerely hope
you will pass house bill 626
which will bring additional funds
to new hampshire's non-profits
in our case
families at the bedside of their loved
ones
nurses protected as they knock on doors
of house-bound patients
all over our state
thank you and i'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you for your testimony tina
andrews
questions from the committee
i see no hands up
uh
no there is no
guarding the wrong i see no hands up
so then we will go to
mario
c-a-p-o-z-z-o-l-i
and mario
is a member of the public representing
all right again i don't see
mario well the last name c-a-p-o-z-z
o l i
okay we will go to the next one
the next one is john
that person oh there we go yep
put his hand up yay
okay and
you found me
he uh
he represents meals on wheels of
hillsborough county
and supports and meets two minutes
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for hearing my testimony i am
the president of meals on wheels of
hillsborough county also known as st
joseph community services
and we provide
meals on wheels to homebound
older adults
as well as adults who have medical
conditions
that make them homebound in addition we
provide community dining and some
transportation services we do that all
over hillsborough county
we do not have a wait list
and we meet the demands every day even
throughout this pandemic
charitable gaming has helped us
immensely
we have received enough money to
help
serve 18 000 meals last year through
charitable gaming
and this is really important especially
through this pandemic
we typically poll
our our clients every year to gauge
their level of
food insecurity as well as their level
of isolation
and
over the past several years
we've asked this question of of them
to say
if you don't you know do you see anybody
else
that visits you other than the meals on
wheels driver you know typically are you
having any other visitors and and 20
have usually said no you know meals on
wheels person is typically the only
person i see all week
since a pandemic that's gone up to 60
percent
uh and and that's really alarming and
we're working on trying to figure out
how to uh impact that
also a number of people who have mism
who aren't eating if we don't send them
food uh that has almost doubled it's
gone up from 16
uh there there is a huge need for our
services i sympathize with all of the
non-profits out there who are doing a
wonderful job
uh
this extra money that would come in from
historic horse racing we estimate would
give us anywhere between
would help subsidize anywhere between
five to ten thousand additional meals
and we we also anticipate the need to
grow so this is a great opportunity to
help us
serve those extra people
uh
and
as a as a another note we have to
fundraise a third of our budget
uh because
state and federal funding just doesn't
cut it
uh and so we support charitable gaming
and we support historic horse racing and
that's my testimony
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the
committee
any questions from the committee
i see none thank you
the next is
patrick cheatham
c-h-e-e-t-h-a-m
and patrick chatham
is a member of the public representing
himself and support needs two minutes to
testify
again
i don't see that name anywhere
if you want to raise your hand if i'm
i don't think so representative major
lewis
chipotle
c-h-i-p-o-l-a
member of the public representing nashua
this is a strain
test a plan that needs zero minutes okay
all right
no no
then i'm going to go to uh rick newman
all right
representative
yes i just i just wanted to note that uh
patrick cheatham who you called a couple
of
names before has sent in a letter of
testimony to us so that's on the record
all right and did he address it to the
12th committee you know i think so yes
yes
the um
rick norman
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
right you're representing the new
hampshire charitable
gaming operators association
that's correct
okay
all right
thank you mr chairman um i will be brief
i know you've had a long day and
i'm rick newman representing the new
hampshire charitable gaming operators
association we support
house bill 626
as a former member of the house i
sympathize with the uh
long hearing and i will be
house bill 626 will provide
something that the charity gaming
facilities today can offer that we don't
have that allows will allow us to
compete with the out-of-state casinos
that
that we do compete with
and as you heard charlie mcintyre say
when encore initially opened charity
gaming in new hampshire took a major hit
in terms of revenue
stabilized a bit right now because of
the covet situation the fact that
encores was down for a while and now
they're operating part-time and they're
not offering poker but that's all going
to change one of these days and we'll be
back to losing the revenue that we saw
that we have the evidence to show you
that we saw when they first opened
um
we
the one thing missing in charity gaming
in new hampshire
is an electronic offering we do not have
that we have we can compete with ten
dollar blackjack and roulette and craps
we have all in poker table stakes poker
but we don't have anything to offer the
player that wants an electronic game
i find it ironic
that
we have opposition from churchill downs
for this churchill downs as you know
owns oxford casino in maine
obviously they know that
uh
this bill will help new hampshire
charity gaming which means an impact on
them but i here's the irony
while
oxford today
churchill downs lobbyist is in new
hampshire opposing this bill
they have another lobbyist in kentucky
supporting the exact same legislation
so
kentucky senate two days ago
passed legislation to authorize
historic racing and the house of
representatives is dealing with it uh
yesterday and today so churchill
uh
is
supporting the bill before they oppose
it
uh obviously i'm a lobbyist too i
totally understand it uh we are here to
present the self-interest of our clients
but i think the committee should be
aware
that the opposition to this coming from
oxford is because of their self-interest
um they are here opposing this bill
for the very reason that we are here
supporting it they know it will help new
hampshire charity gaming and it may
impact revenue
house bill 626 supports new hampshire
charities it supports new hampshire
revenue and it supports new hampshire
jobs we hope you will support these
things too by supporting this bill
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr newman any questions for mr
newman
representative the models
yes i was wondering if there's a figure
of how much in total has gone maybe
on an annual basis to all the charities
that have run through these 16
charitable gaming sites
are you saying i'm talking about since a
charity gaming law was passed in 2006
well even just one year would give us a
ballpark figure sure um
the
charity gaming in new hampshire
generates uh about four million dollars
a year for the charities
and i'm sorry take that back the
generates about 10 to 11 million dollars
a year for the charities and about three
and a half to four million dollars for
the state under the current
limitations that we have i believe the
total so far
benefit to charities
since the law went into effect is
any further questions of mr newman
yeah i do
uh represent ames
sorry i didn't get my hand up um
the
mr newman the
you mentioned
churchill downs
as opposing this bill
i heard their testimony this morning on
the charitable gaming study
but
perhaps i've my attention has been
flagging it's a long day
but um
i'm sorry did you hear me representative
not a word oh i apologize um i i don't
believe they've testified yet but i saw
that they're on the sign up sheet
uh signed up as opposing
uh
representing former representative
strange
was it not peter bragdon
those are all that opposed
house bill 626.
mr chairman if i might yes
sir on the uh sheet you have for people
listed uh to testify
is a peter bragdon
representing
as a lobbyist churchill downs inc in
there's like
190 names
um
but i did highlight those uh opposed
now i might have peter bragging on the
list that i see
[Music]
what page
i think my mind is sort of mine is
sorted by uh
people who want to speak i think yours
is maybe mixed i haven't the fourth
fourth person down on my list
fourth person now on this list
is a tony
is a patrick nealy
yeah i think i got a different sort she
sorted it
for me uh jennifer it's ordered for me
uh just for the people who wanted to
testify
so my list must be sort of different
so those must be a new or less then
she ran it she ran it for me about half
hour before we started this morning
this is supposed to be the official list
right
here i think the way around this form is
just to ask if anybody else who wants to
testify
but peter breitner does not appear to be
on my list but it is on your list
representative major i'm sorry to
interrupt but um mr bragdon did get in
touch
he did not sign up before the eight
o'clock deadline but he did indicate
that he'd like to
um testify on these bills
so that's why it's not on my list
yep
okay
representative major i believe in in mr
brogdon's earlier testimony from today
on another bill he did say he intended
to testify
but he had he didn't testify here
but according to that
it's on pat's list
and
where is it
let him come in i'll talk to him
would you like to take representative
ames and bursting's
questions first i want to take care of
mr bragging
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i i had signed up at 8 30 i
didn't realize the deadline was eight um
the senate deadline is half hour before
the hearings start in the morning so my
apologies for
uh coming in late so
are you in favor of this bill or
opposing the bill uh opposed to the bill
and uh if you have two minutes i'll
explain why
one minute
okay good so um as i mentioned before
churchill downs has gaming facilities in
nine states uh we
operate table games various electronic
games um and obviously because of that
we keep an eye on opportunities across
the country so you may be surprised some
of you to learn that churchill downs as
opposed to hb626
and against what mr newman just told you
there's not the exact same bill being
considered in kentucky
in fact that's the primary reason for
our opposition because even though house
bill 626 makes historic racing machines
more lucrative to the operators than
other gaming in new hampshire
and by that i mean currently charities
get 35 percent of what's left over after
winnings are paid to player with the
state getting 10 the operating in 55.
with this bill the charities rate drops
from 35 of what's left after prizes to
eight and three quarters percent and
then they got to split that with another
charity so maybe you're down to four or
something but let's say it drops it to
eight and three quarters percent so it
becomes much more lucrative for the
operators uh therefore their uh position
of what's left over goes from 55 to 75
percent mr brighton yep can you prepare
a letter
for the rest of it and i think this is
very important mr chair if you look at
page 2 line 22 it says only operators
that hold the license in new hampshire
on may 1st 2020 would be allowed to
operate historic racing machines this is
a restriction on new entries in the
market gives existing operators a
four-year window with no new entries
gives a head start a significant period
entry it's uh the existing operators
don't want the competition they want the
state to pick winners and losers and
they believe that gaming consumers and
charities don't deserve a choice
this exclusion wasn't in prior versions
of the bills these bills started in
2009.
this exclusion appeared last year after
churchill down started asking questions
about new hampshire mr brighton
this
this hearing's been going on since one
o'clock
i've checked the attending list i've
never seen you
raise your hand the hearing is just
about over and all of a sudden you're
coming in at the end
could you prepare what you want us to
know because we're going to have a work
session on it and
provide it to us
we need to move on
and i recovered everybody that wanted to
testify
so i'm closing the public hearing on
house bill
and we will be opening the public
hearing
on house bill
cacr1
i don't think this will be very long
because i have a list
of about
100 and
something names
and
none of them had indicated they want to
testify
but they
87 of them oppose the acr one 17 support
it and
fall on the fine sponsor
representative harrington
cacr1 which provides that an income tax
on earned personal income shall be
prohibited
muted here am i unmuted
yes you are okay thank you mr chairman
appreciate the time here uh this will be
like you said pretty straightforward
it's there's no great mystery here it
simply says we'll not have an income tax
um
i think that uh it would be a
constitutional amendment if we look back
we've uh over the last uh
200 and something years we've done
without a broad-based income tax in new
hampshire and we've managed quite well i
think the events of the last year show
that
even though we had this horrible
pandemic and all sorts of challenges
again we managed to get through it
without an income tax and states around
us uh that had plenty of income tax
didn't do as well as we did i have
relatives down in massachusetts and i
can tell you they're still fighting to
get the first batch of uh vaccines even
though they're
in the first category due to age or
illness but
i just don't see any need for it i think
it's time we went up and stood up and
said
uh let's let the voters decide once and
for all we want to put it in the
constitution i can remember reading
something uh in the newspaper oh i don't
know 30 years ago or something about an
article that was reprinted from the 19 i
think was 1950 saying that a broad-based
tax in new hampshire is inevitable it's
going to happen well it hasn't and it
doesn't have to happen
and it's just quite as simple as that
we've got a wrong track record of
proving we don't need an income tax so
let's put it in the constitution so
instead of having a battle over it every
two years or four years we can put it in
the past and move on to other things and
i'll gladly take any questions
questions for mr uh representative
harrington
mr chair uh president
representative romney i just want to
remind everybody including the uh uh uh
for harrington
we we passed this uh
years ago my first term i guess it was
uh
in the past senate and it did go to the
people
uh
and it was the vote was 58 in favor of
this constitutional amendment
and i used to characterize that as a a
real-time real
poll
of what people thought obviously didn't
make the two-thirds threshold that's
required for a constitutional amendment
to pass it made a 60 threshold in the
house in the senate though
to pass
so uh
again i
uh
would you view this as if anything it'd
be a good way to poll to people if they
still feel the same way to put to bed
once again
whether or not
the people of new hampshire want to see
an income tax
well i think as you said that was in the
past and every year every biennium that
we go through every crisis like the
pandemic that we go through within
without an income tax only proves more
that we don't need one and i think that
given that there's a good chance and i
can't predict what we're going to do it
needs a two-thirds majority of the
people but let's get it out there and
let them have a chance to vote on it
thank you
further questions of mr heron
see no further questions
yeah i'm going to ask one
what's in sucker
uh do you feel uh representative
harrington that the
question of how we're going to have
equitable education
in the state of new hampshire
and the kind of work that's been done in
the last year that shows
that there is vast inequities
in the kind of education that youngsters
receive here do you think that will
change people's minds over time that
perhaps they want to leave it open to
the idea that someday there might be an
income tax
well thank you for your question uh i
really don't know all i can say is the
idea of the uh who thinks the education
fundings are inequitable and what the
problems and issues are have been around
as long as i've been in the legislature
going back to the early 2000s and
actually as long as i've been in new
hampshire which goes back quite a bit
earlier than that so
i don't know and i'm not trying to i'm
not going to judge for the people but i
think that it's an issue that we should
get out there and let them decide
thank you
and those
questions we thank you mr uh
representative harrington for testimony
what i have on the sign up sheet is
17 that support this
87 oppose it
there's a lot of
and
what i'll do
as well as the other is i'll make sure
that
the committee gets a copy of the sign up
sheets
do you want me to read the names
no
okay as long as you have the copies
and there's nobody here
on this 100 and something
that indicate they want to sign up uh
want to speak
there's nobody in the attendees
i keep checking that attendees list
that's why
i get a little disturbed with somebody
who comes in the last minute
or something
um
then i'm going to close the public
hearing on
cacr1
the next the last bill
which is related to taxes providing that
any broad-based sales tax should be
prohibited
and
the sign up first has
in addition to the prime sponsor the
prime sponsors representative harrington
so representative harrington you want to
present
cacr2
[Music]
your muted
okay am i can you hear me now mr
chairman yeah okay thank you uh i will
try to uh
in the essence of saving time basically
ditto what i just said about the last uh
cacr the uh
same position on the broad-based sales
tax we've never had one we don't need
one uh and it's time we put it out for a
vote
i have had one couple of questions on
this and that's not in effect january
1st 2021 because there are some limited
sales taxes in effect in the state now
the one i specifically know about for
example is the um
sales tax on rental cars for example
that would be one so that would not
affect that one this would be going
forward there could be new no new
broad-based tax and like i said i'm not
going to waste your time by repeating
the arguments i just gave for the sale
for the income tax because it's exactly
the same for these and i'll be glad to
take any questions
thank you for your testimony
representative harrington questions from
our questions from the committee let me
look at the attendee rules
thank you um mr harrington
representative harrington sorry on
doesn't
wouldn't this apply also to our our
whole rooms and meals tax to the tobacco
tax to the insurance tax
and um
or or those considered to be not sales
taxes
well thank you for the question by the
way i've been called a lot worse than mr
harrington so don't worry about it
but uh anything that was in effect prior
to january 1st 2021 i would not be
affected by this so the beer tax the
room and meals tax i mentioned the
automobile rental tax any of those
things would not be affected by this
this is going forward prohibition only
doesn't affect anything that's already
enacted into law
thank you i was confusing it with the
other one the other one probably should
have had this language too if it was
are you all set
no further questions uh
anybody else want to testify for or
against oh yes i'm sorry
uh patricia myers
a member of the public representing
herself
who's opposing it
and
i should have looked at this further she
says testifying yes zero minutes so
she got zero minutes you must not be
here
okay um so there's nobody else
testifying
i have a comment while you all were
listening to
testimony i was getting my first
morderner vaccine
at the brown school in berlin and was
able to get back in time to
listen to the last
testimonies but uh
it was not painful and you'll be happy
to know that i got immediately
my appointment for the second
uh shot
on
this has been overcoming a lot of
obstacles
i do have my first shot
i was scheduled for the 18th of this
month
and then i was able to get it on the
third of this month
the medina shot and they scheduled me
for the third of
march
so did you get a little sticker the way
i got just i got a sticker and i got a
little card yeah i got the card
apparently that's
very totally i'm really happy my wife is
too
i'm told by the major hospital in my
area that there's no way we can skip the
line and i'm stuck at the end of march
to start you know what i'm
sharpening my duties
uh on house on cacr2 any more questions
comments et cetera
and then i'm closing the public hearing
on cacr2
now we can continue i believe mr or
representative murphy has a question
representative murphy
question it was just that representative
tucker took me down memory lane
i went to the brown school and i lived
where is the brown school it's right by
the river uh on the north side of town
okay
the thing about the brown school is it
was in operations kind of an elderly
building
but they adapted it for a k3
but berlin had to close its last
elementary
last school built as an elementary
school last year because of the lack of
education funds
so there are no children in it now i've
not been in it since there were children
and
[Music]
they now are in a
a building that was built as a high
school
that was became a middle school when my
new high school was built
50 or 60 years ago and uh so
you just brought me down memory lane
that's all yeah
i want to thank everybody for hanging in
here just about everybody did hang in i
i apologize for getting a little rough
there at the end of the other
name but
that kind of upset me
anyway
um
i would like to apologize for dropping
out for quite a while i got a reporter's
request then i i had to talk to somebody
else about the governor's
speech
so
all right
any other comments we will get i'm going
to have jenny jenny
yes
i'll get ahold of jen
and
to uh
email you
all a copy of the sign up sheets so you
have
i think you're talking about gen 4
aren't you yeah gen 4
i could just forward them because she
if you'd like um at the
the blue sheet closes
at the very end of the day
so if um someone could just send me a
reminder i can send the final final
version in the morning
well if you make sure you send me the
final final version i couldn't
appreciate it absolutely and that's what
goes into the file so i'll actually you
don't have to remind me i'll uh make a
note for myself in the morning and i'll
send you
all the final um
blue sheets for today's bills okay so
jennifer will send those to their
committee members
anything else
we will have these work sessions um
we've got to analyze what the governor's
budget did and
we'll get together and discuss that
so next week
okay
what's that
on i was just trying to estimate it for
mary jane walner
and on it doesn't look like the impact
is
huge
as especially not as as the tax cut
bills going through now
but
there's one part of it that i think we
are incapable of beginning to estimate
that dra would be able to
which is the reduction in the amount of
money
uh of of the floor the increase of the
floor for the bpt
uh from
150 enterprise level to
250 enterprise level i don't think we've
ever asked for an estimate of what that
does
we'll better look at
what he's proposing and then we will be
meeting with the budget director
on the 18th
so if we do our homework we should be
able to ask them some pretty quick
questions
i was hoping maybe we could ask the dra
yes
i i already plan to do that
all right anything else
before we break up
yes uh mr chairman
yes
relative to local option for sports
betting
tuesday because monday is a holiday next
representative hacken phillips has her
hand up
okay
thank you mr chair i just had something
in my calendar marked for
tomorrow at 3 p.m a caucus with finance
is that happening
on that is a democratic focus okay i
thought it was a joint thing okay thank
you
sorry
our decision sir yeah
i've got all county
business tomorrow so everybody have a
good weekend
bye-bye